welcome to the show i'm just trying to
put it all together
i've been such a fan of yours for so
long um
you maybe have the only joke about the
pandemic i can tolerate
it is such a beautifully crafted bit
just about the special yes just about
your special about when
the back and forth of the news of we're
gonna die we're gonna let we can go
inside we can't you do the most
beautiful bit about it was that
something that you developed over time
or did you write it on stage or do you
actually write something out i write
everything on stage
i write everything on stage i don't
really um what i do is i just think for
a really long time
like for hours hours and hours chappelle
and i joke about this and he's the one
who gave me the visual he's like you're
like that get out poster you're just
there and then like a tear pole
crocodile yeah yeah just like oh god
it's too much thinking and that's where
i just like frame everything in my head
and then i just take it on stage and
something about like the reaction of the
audience inspires a line that i would
have never thought about otherwise wow
yeah it's just how i write everything
and particularly that
the pandemic bit i guess you can call it
but it's really just like a government
bid a money a bit about money about
everything about everything all
in one was during the pandemic when
chappelle was doing those shows in the
cornfield and i was writing the show
and it was like a really stressful time
to do anything and i was writing the
show pandemics happening civil unrest
george floyd like it's just a disaster
of a situation
and thankfully he had this relief and i
was just like i was doing all this
material pre-pandemic like i had a like
90 minutes that i was touring i was like
that's all dead how about that and i
just go up and i just took this anxiety
with me on stage
and it birthed something very special
and related on such a deep level to put
the audience
and i just kept going with it and it was
initially like a 10 to 12 minute bit of
just
me just frantically just going back and
forth with all these things that are
bouncing around our minds and people
were losing their minds they were
feeling the anxiety with me i was like
this is incredible it was so cathartic
it was it was actually like for me i
as a comedian i kind of know what people
why people see comedy like i i'm not i'm
still not entirely sure you know whether
it's to see someone that you like
whether it's to go laugh whether it's to
take someone on a date whether for me
it's always like oh you're going to
basically let someone else think for you
for two hours do you know what i mean to
surrender you know your brain to someone
else and to go through this haunted
house in places you would never go and
think wait someone you let someone else
think for you and i'm like okay got it
even as a comedian i'm not entirely sure
but watching that bit
was like
it was like healing in a way that was
like oh my god like
how did he know that that's exactly what
i went through
and i was like oh it was so cathartic
and as a comedian i have not had that
experience
watching another comedian it was just
like such a thrill it's a huge comment i
i
i was just so in a s weird space not we
we all were but specifically for me like
writing the show
going through that i shortly separate
from my wife after they got divorced
shortly after that too so it was just
like an odd time she got sick of uh
chappelle giving you covet yeah probably
probably that and chappelle or maybe yes
which one do you want i pick coven what
we now take a break of me flirting with
moe ammer i'm a manic person and i
people ask they're like
you know how do you have so much energy
it's like i don't like i'm running on
adrenaline and fear
um
and the formaldehyde from decaf coffee i
don't know i have spent my entire life
uh trying to be able to sleep well i've
done every medication that has like
screwed up my memory i mean you've seen
what people are like is she on drugs
which sometimes we are on the podcast
now on during our live shows but um i'm
like i just think i have some brain
damage and memory issues from
prescription drug sleeping pills which i
now find to be no bueno i love the movie
memento but i don't want to live like
the star of it so thank god and then
also but you know that my other problem
is that i think a lot of things are
scams and a lot of things are just
placebo effect trash and in the cbd
space especially in the last couple
years i'm like let me i'm gonna jump in
when you guys have figured it out right
this is the one that we have settled on
it is called next evo naturals triple
action cbd sleep it is so unbelievable
and also has four times better cbd
absorption and it's not just another cbd
company they're all natural products are
backed by more scientific studies than
any other cbd brand developed by
experienced consumer healthcare and
pharmaceutical professionals this is the
real deal and that's how they got their
hands on the smart sword technology
which improves cbd's ability to be
absorbed getting into your system in as
little as 10 minutes emily loves this as
someone who's so self-absorbed i love it
stop wondering if see we're going to
talk about that later stop wondering no
no we won't obviously stop wondering if
cbd is right for you try next evo
naturals capsules gummies mints and
topical creams clinically proven to be
better absorbed by your body get 25 off
your next order of 40 or more at
nextevo.com with promo code whitney
that's 25 off at
n-e-x-t-e-v-o dot com promo code whitney
back to mo
it's one of those things it was just
like it's such a unique time
and all these like really special people
were just popping in like letterman came
through
which was like one of my favorite things
ever because i really like that was our
dream right you got to get on letterman
that's the thing you know after carson
it was like get on letterman yeah
and i was supposed to do letter and then
he left like six months after and i
ended up doing colbert it was fine it
was great obviously colbert is amazing
and it's a late show he's still part of
that legacy he just really wanted to do
that so when he showed up
i just
i just like let me know if he's there
that's it and when he was there in the
corner
i was like i'm performing for letterman
like i could give a shit about anybody
else here like this is for you
and i just did like i think it was like
literally over 12 12 12 minute bit of me
going back and forth and dissecting
everything that's happening
and uh just being as frantic and as
crazy as possible pumped and he just
went bananas for it he just went bananas
for it he just kept repeating my name on
stage
sweet things and the next you know we
got on a call like about three weeks
later just to talk you know just to have
a conversation who are you like get to
know me get to know him like kind of
thing it was really
really special
it was right before i
left my storage unit with all my
belongings so it was kind of like
that's how like it works people think
you're living lazy super glamorous life
and you are in some ways you definitely
are but the deeply personal stuff is
just
so potent and
is that he grew up watching letterman
was letterman like what was your first
sort of like i want to do that
um
no stand up you mean yeah or it will
stand up or like because you know stand
up is yeah i think a lot of people
forget it's a uniquely american art form
i always forget that's a weird thing
it's an indigenous american art form
there's three
and stand-up comedy yeah but did you
when was letterman sort of your always
been your comedy hero like icon
uh definitely on the late night side for
sure it was only one like my mom knew
you know right of course here's like
where all foreigners were immigrants to
america came in 90. my mom knows who
letterman is like that's a big deal like
my mom knows letterman and all the game
show hosts you haven't made it until
your mom knows someone you're in the
photo with right absolutely i i mean i
remember coming here and being like how
do i get on like jeopardy yeah exactly
no for real
yeah my mom loved him loved alex trebek
and and rest in peace she just
absolutely loved it she saw me i think
we were in abu dhabi for the formula one
thing and all the celebrities like
go there's like certain celebrities that
love this formula one shit and everybody
goes and then gathers there and i happen
to
be there as well and dave was there and
everybody but she i took a picture was
me
dave and steve harvey and my mom was
like steve harvey
my son is like up there i'm like jesus
todd taught me everything i know a
little book called act like a lady think
like a man
very ostensibly problematic book but
totally changed my life and i would not
have been proposed to a couple times
even though they fell apart had it not
been for steve harvey's book are you
serious yes bitch act like a lady thinks
like a man is the most fucked up book
but it is true as all hell so it's steve
harvey basically saying i don't know why
but i really like you calling me bitch
right now oh sorry i thought i really
like i liked it it was kind of weird
that was like just to the to she was
like yes bitch i was like yeah
all right where is this going usually
i'm like what the fuck did you say
this one just the way you said it the
way it slipped out i was like bitch is
like shit it's you know what it is alone
i would have sprayed it on right now
i've got some ck one right here
i
was saying dude for a while and i was
like that is so not no bitch is way
better don't you like bitch it's more
just like i'm a drag queen i love it so
yeah so it's not calling you it it's i
get it i got that vibe from it it's my
way of going to everybody like bitch
this person is
when someone doesn't get credit where
credit is due even if i have plenty of
uh
ways to clown them i go bitch but we
cannot forget
that steve harvey wrote this huge book
that nobody really talks about how much
they use it it's called act like a lady
think like a man and the whole thing is
like ladies
so glad that you're equal so glad that
you you know um are getting everything
you want in life and you can have it all
done but could you just wear a fucking
skirt every now and then
would it kill you yeah to let to pretend
you can't open the pickle jar so just
ask us to do something for you we need
to feel useful
okay don't go so
feminist
that we have nothing to do i feel like
you dragged me out to like really
dangerous waters but i'm safe
but any moment
i can just fucking sink so i'm just
gonna listen
which men don't do you know what i mean
she's gonna listen
like a good bitch
i'm just gonna be this
good polite bitch and you're gonna do
this how do you say it you know like
it's how you say it so i took it very
well i've reclaimed the word bitch yeah
and it just now means listen yeah okay
fine
i love it i think it's great everyone
listen i'm gonna champion somebody yeah
that everybody's mad at um but uh that
is really funny i am really pulling you
into this yeah he's like why do you want
me to respond
i'm like well okay yes that's it yeah
like things are going well for you
you feel about that on top of the world
you're on fire you have a you have a you
know superhero movie coming out with the
rock october 21st so how do you feel
about women's right now but i think we
could all agree the neighborhood's full
of shit right
yes no that's fine i could publicly say
that that's
i have no problem
it's too much
that's too i've seen crazy and that's
god bless her you know it's a rough one
that's a rough one i um
remember like
watching your special and there is such
a a
joy
in you like an impis joy like you're so
brilliant you've been through so much
and i was like what the fuck is my
excuse
like you know what i mean i remember
just enough of course we're performing
whatever but you're so um astute and so
beautifully and so elegantly
um lace in the themes of ancestral
trauma in your tv show like
do you feel like this joyfulness and
this in writing comedy is like a
survival mechanism is this your natural
disposition have you had to work hard to
stay in a positive space right
yeah it's just um it was a multi-layered
answer so one is my mom told me directly
like ah this makes sense when were like
two years old
you would just turn off the tv and start
performing in front of the tv so there
was like this seed that was there that i
didn't even know it was planted right
and then there's
the the war that happened that removed
us from kuwait and ended up in houston
texas
and then there was just like the space
of like trying to figure out what
make sense of it all
and
i was always like a storyteller
with my friends like
uh when i was like six seven years old
the neighborhood would all go around i
would just tell just spontaneously start
telling them stories and i'm completely
making i was gonna say not the same
thing i was such a liar yes again
fucking lying my ass off if you want to
frame it that way fine
i was thinking a kid with a great
imagination
pathological life you say tomato i them
to laugh so it's permissible okay and
that is the best medicine therefore i am
a doctor i am a medical doctor yes thank
you thank you
i have a degree i haven't printed it yet
but it's fine no because i'm green it
was because
it was always like part of my life and
then when that happened
you know leaving fleeing the war ended
up in houston texas and figuring out
what's going on then being introduced to
stand up at 10 i was like that's what
i'm gonna do and i figured out and every
time something super serious would
happen i find myself cracking a joke
or you know
finding a way to to make other people
laugh that are not feeling well it's
just interesting um i was born to do it
100 it was just like like imagine all
the things that had to happen for me to
get where i am yeah like my parents had
to leave uh palestine to go to kuwait
right and to flee that to to go my dad
got a job in kuwait you spend i don't
know 30 years there have me all that the
war happens you end up in houston texas
my dad dies all these things start
happenings
uh tragic things
that happen to a kid so young
but then there's just like drive they're
like oh i'm supposed to be a stand-up
comedian this is what i'm gonna do and
then my your mentor at 17 tells you it's
20 years for overnight success and
you're like yeah
let's go
not even thinking about it and then
everybody's looking at you like you're
crazy like this guy is
out of his mind thinking that this is so
achievable
and
and then you're right
you know i was right 100 all my
instincts were right all everything that
i felt inside was correct and it was
incredibly therapeutic for me
although being broke and sleeping in
your car and fucking doing one-nighters
across the south as a muhammad in a
post-9 11 era it was terrifying at times
it was absolutely necessary
it's so wild i was talking to emily
about this earlier because i was like i
remember as a kid watching on the news
what was going on in the gulf war but
people my our age
got kind of fucked in terms of learning
about this because it happened when we
were so young yeah so you're not really
understanding it right and then by the
time it's kind of oh you know it's not
going to be in history books by the time
you're really in high school it's more
of current events yeah you know yeah
exactly and then you know we're too busy
learning that the pilgrims and the
native american indians just had fun
dinners right we're learning shit that
didn't happen right instead of you know
what's actually currently happening and
then by the time you're out of college
that's when it's probably getting into
history books but we're yeah it's almost
like living through it and you know the
least about it it's also like such a
fucked up privilege of americans that
our parents just had to say to us like
hey something scary's happening on but
you don't need to worry about it do you
know what i mean like we didn't have
wars like boots on the ground like
something was happening overseas and our
we were seven so our parents weren't
going to be like let's talk about the
like what we're doing right now you know
sure sure as an adult you have to go hey
i don't know anything i was alive during
it but i don't i was all i saw was
monica lewinsky news at that time there
was some which is important there was
come on there was a come on adjust from
the gap okay that had real problems that
they did explain yeah
yeah at six years old they explained the
car the cigar and the pussy yeah yeah
[Laughter]
do you want to smell my cigar we have
our priorities straight okay i smell my
cigars
i don't know
we're very worldly she was wearing a
french beret
okay she was really ahead of her time we
are nothing if not
yeah you're right but was there a i just
think
i'm just thinking about you coming over
that time
was it frustrating that americans
probably didn't know that much about
your circumstance or was there a relief
of like okay i can just
try to not have to think about it
yeah you don't really have time to be
frustrated
in those
you just have to like survive yeah it's
not about like oh they don't understand
me i just don't feel like i just feel
like these these kids in texas see me
yeah they don't stop talking about
monica
yeah there's no time for like that and i
have no problems like making friends and
all that it was just like the
the
like the social gap like i didn't even
know what cool was or you know i didn't
know that there was a thing as like
being cool versus the uncool like i
didn't even that concept was so
different is that just a uniquely was
that a uniquely american concept at the
time for me like it was was not maybe a
western thing but definitely not like
a kid in kuwait like going to private
british english school like we didn't
know like oh this person's cool that
person is not cool like so i didn't have
time for any of that it was just
survival it was constantly like survival
learning
uh i was making friends it was not a
problem like making friends it was just
more like adjusting from british english
to american english
so many different embarrassed myself
regularly
uh just
like to understand that there's such
drastic differences in english from
british to
is
wild to me like i asked my teacher for a
rubber one time the front of the whole
class
is the stream can i get a rubber
they're like what they're probably like
this kid's really fucking yeah
yeah he's already getting it
and then i would call cat's pussy you
know like i didn't know and kids
wouldn't correct me because they enjoyed
having fun with me
like you know me saying that and then uh
but then it's weird because then some
guys call other guys cats like this cat
over here yeah that's pretty funny i
never even thought just like how i'm
trying something english yeah wait hold
on yeah no it was like what up dog what
yeah it was the whole situation it was
so funny i didn't even think about that
but he's just adjusting and and i didn't
really have time to think about and then
in the moment also speaking about this
like
understanding what was going on and the
moment i had
anger towards a particular person or a
leader and then you grow up and realize
oh it's way more complex
than what i had it
and it's it's
it's america it's america running this
whole ship it's pretty amazing the
greats greats are able to
you know infuse something with um
incredibly serious dark painful you know
traumatic content but somehow just you
have this instinct you know how to like
perfectly dose it out so that
you know the viewer doesn't shut down
yeah and start going okay i don't want
to think about i'm this is too painful
that you like
it seems like the way you know your
character navigates it obviously
probably how you navigate it in life but
is there ever a time where you're like
because people don't want to be preached
to either it's like people's egos get
involved and they're like don't make me
feel bad don't make me feel guilty i
don't want to feel all those on my night
off right you know exactly but i still
you know want to be educated about this
and want more empathy and obviously this
and also the show's just fucking funny
yeah it's also just fucking great
regardless like that's what i keep
saying about it like oh it's how you
it's a great way to learn about the
palestinian-american experience of
someone that it's also just a hilarious
fucking show yeah you know so but are
there ever conversations where you're
like
like let me dose this out or or do you
think about just about my life the
comedy with tragedy and what the ratio
should be yeah that's well all my life
has been that for sure like balancing it
out and but also in stand-up so you
can't give them too much and also like
you got to be funny yes the number one
thing it's got to be hilarious you can't
just be up there trying to teach people
like no me being on stage is a teacher
is a teaching moment like
i was performing and i'm talking about
every nook and cranny in the fucking
south
pre-911 as a teenager and then 9 11
happens and it's just like oh just being
me
and being funny is significant enough
that's right that's already
revolutionary yeah that's already a
thing if i come up here and i'm ignorant
it's already progressed exactly just
anything just you got to be funny and
then like oh
you know like people walk up to me
regularly and this happened to a lot of
other comedians arab comedians later on
is like you don't look arab you know
what i mean like this happens so you
start understanding oh man there's so
much but also to deliver how do you know
yeah exactly you don't look arab
yeah yeah well it's based off of what
the brain been fed for the last x amount
of years right well i mean hollywood has
depicted arabs for a certain way yeah
yeah for like 80 years since the 30s
yeah yeah it's been crazy you don't look
like the arabs at the seventh vail strip
club you know
in the paintings and the windows it's so
weird like where what are you basing
this on mel gibson in black faces yes i
mean confident like well you don't look
arab you know i read a thousand and one
nights and uh yeah you know you've seen
arabian nights
aladdin you don't look like an aladdin
out here where's your carpet is it in
your back pocket y'all fold them up like
that y'all got is this some kind of
trick i do not see a camel anywhere yeah
i just kind of it's exactly right so
that's one
and then and then realizing like oh man
spreading it out is important like in
your set
because it's it's because i find you
know i i'm just fascinated by and i
think this is part of the reason i've
been a little bit like um
uh you know the spinny wheel on the
computer yeah the rainbow wheel the
rainbow wheel i kind of have that with
you because i'm going i don't want to do
that thing in this interview that people
always do to me which is like i'm just a
female comedian right you know what i
mean and then that's all i can't just be
a comedian but then when someone is just
like oh you know because me comedians do
this and this i'm like
yeah but also being a woman is it is so
it's weird it's like sometimes i want to
be identified as the female comedian and
then other times i don't and i'm just
curious like where you are in terms of
like i really want to lean into this
part of myself and this part of my
identity but sometimes i just want to be
a fucking comedian yeah no it's a it's a
tough one it's a really tough one so i'm
gonna continue on this like spreading it
out and i'm gonna answer that question
so then like i realized like in my stand
i remember listening to a bill hicks
album and he was getting really
sophisticated in his stand up like there
was a moment where he was just
really smart and
and the crowd is really quiet and then
he goes don't worry i'm gonna get to the
dick jokes you know what i mean it's
just one of those things that's kind of
a reliever like oh you can't give people
too much information at once too real
the quiet all that is you gotta dose it
out
that's that's one and then it just
lended itself to the tv show where i
knew like i didn't want it to be a hyper
political show like i don't want it to
be so politicized that people miss the
funny the story the heart
the attachment to the characters because
politics can get really tricky you know
people will have their own views and
what am i going to try to change i'm not
trying to change your views you know i
just want you to relate
to this palestinian family it's history
i'm a palestinian-american
came here as a refugee who's created his
own show
who's cast
a palestinian family aside from my the
guy who plays my brother omar elbow
who's phenomenal he's egyptian but he
worked on the dialect like everything
was so specific and accurate
and it was really important to me to
like for people to
um understand the characters feel the
story attach themselves to them and then
you can just have the dialogue come here
and there you don't need
to be over the top whether you're going
to lose people i don't want to lose
people i don't care i really genuinely
don't care what you believe in as long
as you listen like
i'll listen to you and there was this
great quote my friend
told me that his teacher taught him he
said i forgot i'm trying to get this
right so i don't have a bush moment
right here on his show
he says i'll listen to you
with the possibility of you being right
and i want you to listen to me with the
possibility that i might be right like
just have this open mind
or maybe we're both a little right maybe
both little right maybe together we can
yeah but just listening the bottom line
is like trying to listen to each other
and get there i think is what's
important and your second question this
last one was no clue no clue i couldn't
tell you no come on oh it was so boring
how much of your experience you want oh
how like do you vacillate back and forth
of just in terms of like some days i'm
like you know people like you've done so
much for women and comedy yeah yeah
they're not comedy
and then exactly another time someone's
like yeah being a comedian at the comedy
store every night until 2 a.m it's
pretty hard i'm like it is harder like
that all of a sudden i want more i want
to be a woman all of a sudden hilarious
and like when do you want to just be a
comedian and when do you want to be a
caring comedian yeah comedian all the
time like the press specifically loves
framing it as like muslim comedian you
know coming like bro i'm not doing
muslim comedy i have done comedy for
muslims comedy exclusively yeah i mean
i'm in new york just killing myself like
i just got
okay you want an hour i can't do an hour
i do 55 minutes
uh
no yeah roll out the it's not a red
carpet but yeah i'm a comedian man it's
the religion is separate from it um
you know people will
it's a historic thing what i'm doing so
people are going to want to attach
totally things to it and i'm fine with
that people will do that and they'll do
that but in the end i'm a comedian man
we're all like
we're all one gender we're all one race
like we really are man comedians are
just like
unique human beings that
here's something that fascinated me as i
was watching your show because it's very
um
i guess i'm just gonna like say
fashionable right now but also in comedy
to me very like sloppy
and reductive and elitist to
go like everyone from texas is uh
ignorant everyone in the in
the midwest is dumb and everyone you
know it's just like a i think that and i
don't even blame people that make these
generalizations be in a way because i i
always try to find how can i get the
compassion it either means you don't
know these people you don't go to these
places or you just need to blame someone
because it's an anesthesia to feel
better about how stressful everything is
right now you know i know how powerful
blame can be you know there's a school
shooting well fuck those q anons
i feel better okay like now i know you
know what i mean it's because there's
nothing you can do about it and the
brain needs a way to self-suit and a lot
of times it's maligning so
but
the scene where you're selling the
sneakers to the guy from texas yeah that
character like you could have very
easily and i see a lot of writers rooms
and a lot of who would very quickly or
it would be funny to them to
make that character a cartoon right
racist uh ignorant just whatever
maybe for a cheap laugh but ultimately
throwing your character in the whole
ultimate under the bus because there
would be a meanness behind it right and
truly my favorite moment
in that episode was when you say i'm
entrepreneur and he goes good for you
yeah yeah that's great only a writer
would cash it was so sincere too yeah
good for you yeah yeah that's a hell of
a job
it was just such a human moment and it
was such a even if this guy from texas
in your brain is a viewer you're going
uh he probably has a gun or he probably
is right you're like that moment was
just
yeah i'm tired of this like idea that
that
first of all all texans are this way and
then some will surprise you like oh shit
yeah man me my dad used to work out in
saudi arabia
shit i love that land with their eyes
and shit and you know we ain't with our
hands and you know like will shock you
so
until you have that experience and then
and then houston specifically is such a
diverse city
it's the most diverse city in america
and people don't know that they have
this idea of what it is
like basically uh you don't look arab
you know like the same idea behind that
is the same
thing with houston this projection of
like we're all on horses yeah hey people
just imagine that and there is they're
fucking you might be you might be at a
stoplight and a horse crossed the road
are you sure that wasn't one of those
plastic horses outside walmart no no you
put a penny in no that was just
i'm telling you everyone's on horses
yeah yeah it's just like black cowboys
will just roll up out of nowhere it's
amazing but it's like the idea of of
like
everybody's that way it's not it's like
the you respect the hustle and it's and
it's more so the character to be able to
assimilate in any situation that scene
was about like it's a kickoff like man
he can change
yeah exactly with anyone he knows
exactly how to anticipate other people's
needs you can read someone that is
number one a huge comedian thing you
know that's one of the greatest skills
comedians have is like we can look in
the front row and go they're on a bad
date they're going through a divorce
that was a groupon
they thought joe rogan was going to be
here yeah he's not coming he's not going
to be here so sorry and yeah so whatever
but so you're able to do that do you
feel like your skill to be able to do
that also came from the trauma of having
to shape-shift as a refugee of like
definitely talked to a social worker and
i have to go to this court thing and i
have to yeah hyper you gotta like i'm a
hyper assessor like we are as comedians
but some are just like more elite than
others hyper vigilant i could just like
hear more than most i can see more than
most i can assess people's realities
really quickly like it's scary one time
i did this trick with my friends we were
at a weirdo like club wait like this is
what i was doing at a club was hilarious
in my early 20s we just went out i'm
like this girl just broke up with her
man i could just tell she just broke up
with him these girls are taking her out
to make her feel good i can just tell
they're like bullshit i was like fuck it
let's just go and ask you know she's
like you just broke up with your man she
starts bawling
you know like i was like oh i'm sorry i
was just like trying to tell my friends
i could assess people really well and i
think that you're just going through
this and i just like had a bet to win
they're like whoa did somebody tell you
like i was like nobody told me oh my god
and i did it like six times in a row
everybody just quit all my boys just
like quit like this is crazy i always
want to talk about how your traumas can
give you an advantage in life you know
um and so but about that's if you're not
if you're not super focused on the
trauma and you're more focused on trying
to get out of it and understand it and
be better for it some people just love
being a fucking victim that's right
that's right like some people just can't
live without being poor me look at me
what happened to me
and they just never get out of it i'm
like you're never gonna make it you
gotta break out you gotta break out of
that shit and like you did that i want
to go back to something you said too
like how often you talk about being arab
on stage and like how do you parse that
out it's like you know when i was doing
it
it's like this weird thing where
ethnic comedians that are basically
non-white comedians and not even black
just different like say pakistani or
southeast asian or whatever like they
would look at me sometimes and be like
oh he's just doing stuff about his
family is perceived like hacky
right like it's no it's weird like i
know it's weird but it's like perceived
as hacky buy hacks by hacks but that's
different but also but also they're just
so trying to be something they're not
they were trying to imitate what white
comedians are doing
and like just trying to be they're
fucking a stool fucking a stool or
whatever they're doing they're trying to
all sound like mitch hedberg everybody
sounds like a chapter and then and then
what happened later on years down the
line those comedians walk up to me and
be like man you know i've always been
just scared to talk about
where i come from and what i do now
everybody's doing it right like
everybody's doing it initially it was
just like this thing like no man you
just need to know how to write i can
write jokes but i can write jokes i
prefer to tell stories i mix it up i can
sit on a stool i can i can i can be
really animated i can smash a watermelon
yeah well definitely won't do that but
but the point is is that having as many
weapons in your in your holster as
possible is what it's about it's not
about just being are you a sit-down
comedian are you uh you know are you
contemplative and in a corner and like
you all sound the fucking same yeah you
know it's about getting as many tools in
your tool bed as possible yeah and being
able to work any room like that's the
shit that's the shit and to be as
personal as possible while you're doing
it
was like super fascinating to me and i
noticed it from the beginning that this
needed to happen
and that's why i mix it like this is
what i am this is what it is this is my
observation it's always if you look at
all my the two specials they're very
mixed a limiting belief
that hollywood
morons uh hold where they go oh well
this person has such a specific
experience right palestinian refugee
like not everyone can relate it's such a
small sliver or something right or they
go oh this person is half
you know half asian half hispanic so
that's such a small but what
you know i think we're learning and
people like you ronnie youssef go the
more specific you are the more universal
you actually are right right so it's
like even though the optics are not
exactly the same like your show i feel
like i related to more than any show
about an entitled white woman yeah um
no it's it's like by design like danny
martinez is such an incredible mentor of
mine he owned the comedy showcase was no
longer there but he mentored rafi may
uh r.i.p ralphie and there's so many
guys that went on to have like
successful careers in hollywood and he
took me under his wing when i was 17. he
taught me early on be universal also be
able to write clean yeah like being able
to be clean at any moment in time like i
want you to write clean
it's just like you forced me into that
situation and i'm i love using the word
fuck fuck it's so funny to say like fuck
you fuck this fuck that fuck not you
know like it's just so much fun to play
with and he just put me in this mindset
it's like man you can always be dirty
you can always go down you can always do
this but man if you have that in your
arsenal you're unstoppable and be
universal even though your background is
so incredible and especially in the
beginning i think comedians since we're
such like punk rock like we don't follow
the rules we challenge authority so the
idea of conforming in any way or
deluding ourselves like i think i see
i'm being silenced also focus if i want
it's like okay but also like we're
business people i think the most
successful comedians the happiest ones
are the ones that also can do business
but you know what i can also do this
without saying fuck so i can do
corporate gigs i can do cruises i can do
i need to whatever bob mitzvahs whatever
the fuck you need to do you know and you
only become stronger as a comedian as
someone who built this house uh on the
word fuck um i
oh my god what if i just did bar
mitzvahs and they didn't know i was like
palestinian
like a super clean comedian that never
talked about my background and somehow i
just get booked about mitzvahs and i'm
just
i'm fascinated by it because there are
times i do have imposter syndrome where
i'll be like without
you know the ability to go into those
incendiary areas or say curse words am i
funny at all like sometimes i'll do it
also just to challenge myself the most
um edgy thing you can do right now is be
vulnerable and kind of wear your heart
on your sleeve and be open i'm the worst
at that i just do it all the time and
it's irritating like the first two
specials like i didn't mean to have like
my mom is in the audience i didn't
factor in that this is going to be hyper
emotional for my mom so much
seeing like 1300 people lose their minds
through the paramount theater and
you just like look out and your mom's
bawling and just like you didn't know
you didn't realize like oh shit you know
like
oh man i came out of her yeah i came out
of her like it's just crazy and she
yeah she popped me out and
like this accident is now like becoming
a star this is
wow i did not see that coming
and then you know i just talked to tell
the story of how she got us out of
kuwait it just happened
in the first special where i just talked
about it
which becomes the flashback in episode
seven that i wrote years ago
and then in ep in uh in muhammad in
texas my second special
i go back on to do an encore crowd was
going crazy i was like well if i
go back out if if they go nuts i'll go
back out and i'll tell this story the
first time i went to palestine since the
you know i have the wall in the
background and i have the mexican
partition between texas and mexico then
i'll go tell this story it's a great
story and i'll just get out of there
it'll be sweet so i tell the story and
it just happens to be like so it's just
it is an amazing story
and then in post
i'm like wait i think i have the footage
of when i actually the first time in
2009 i was able to go back to palestine
i was like where's this footage
i can't find it anywhere i find a hard
drive it's broken i send it to the
fucking emergency room it's literally an
urgent care like they're working on it i
call my friend andrea kalin who's an
amazing documentarian director out of dc
she i was like do you happen to have
some externals of mine it's been so long
she was let me check and she goes these
say mo nablus i'm like i think those are
the ones
of the experience of me going back to
palestine for the first time
and then i intercut it into the spot i
got it i was supposed to turn the
special in the next day wow and i it was
that kind of situation and then
everybody was like i don't know if it's
gonna work and this and that put it
together everybody's watching us crying
crying i'm just like shit what did i
just do and it became like a dedication
to my father which i'm very proud of it
was not a it was not like it was not a
purpose it was just something that
happened naturally
and both specials are like that and the
show of course is gonna be the series is
gonna have this kind of heart it's
something that you i just can't like get
away from it's who i am
you know deeply personal and i think the
more personal you are
the bigger the connection and also i
sleep better yeah
i sleep a lot better because you get to
leave it all on the floor yeah like i
got to get like get this all out and
give it to y'all and now i get to
almost um yeah episode three is like a
real thing i found out about my dad
being tortured at the lawyer's office
this and that i realized i didn't even
like mourn it properly in my own life
and so like doing the scene i broke down
i genuinely like just lost my shit while
you were shooting it yeah while i was
shooting it i was just like i was so
focused on the thing because the
dialogue
that i wrote that put together for that
was you know intended for him to space
out and get there like to be so focused
on the thing that happened to his father
and once i sat there with it
and it was so quiet
in a church
it's dark
bumby's voice my dear friend
so soothing like just felt made me feel
so comfortable
i just lost my shit
everybody was like that was amazing that
was just like oh nobody could make eye
contact with me after we
yeah that was like everyone was just
like feels like you just shot a porn
like a triple gang banger it was like so
weird i feel weird i've never done this
before
you know to be so like
honest like that
and then i remembered chappelle telling
me one day he goes be so honest it's
hard to make eye contact with you
and that was the first time i actually
experienced it where everyone was like
yeah
you know wiping their tears like doing
this thing and nobody really wants to
look at you and it's like oh that was so
real
even for me i'm having problems
everybody else around you is just like
yeah yeah and um you know just only for
little doses they'll look at you and
then look away i was like this is great
this is very cathartic
is it real it's honest it's the kind of
television i want to make
it's just
doesn't get realer than that the choice
that i saw that you kept in was this
sort of all business like swallow it
white knuckle it swallow it you know and
is that in your life uh a coping
mechanism that you like
you know
used of just like because my thing is
like there's certain things where like
if i start crying i'll just like never
stop like maybe there are certain things
you know like tools like denial and just
and but so elegantly did i see i'm like
good i remember saying the character
like good block that out that's good
yeah yeah
i was like best case scenario is just
swallow it and just let it crystallize
into cancer yeah exactly i was like yeah
yes
perfect and that's what most people do
and i definitely did that i was like if
i was your therapist i would say god
forbid it turns into cancer
i would say that was a perfect way of
handling this denial just give me the
papers let's move right and then the
incredible uh uh scene where you're a dj
in the strip club and there's a guy
smoke and it just it's gonna come out
yeah
it's in there it's gonna come out when
it if you won't let it out if you're not
gonna feel the feelings if you're not
gonna exercise them and face them
they're going to find their way out and
it's going to look
it's going to look nasty was that
something that happened in real life
where you felt like
yeah i
i found out in the lawyer's office it's
how i found out about my dad after
i became a citizen at that point so it's
different from the story line and i
looked in the folder i was like what is
this picture
what is that picture
and he was just like um
your dad like he just so surprised i was
like yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah okay
okay cool cool cool cool cool you know
like that yeah yeah yeah yeah
ah he passed away many years ago you
know i got wrestling how would i have
mercy on this song okay i just bounced
and i realized like i never
i just like buried it it was over yep
never dealt with it didn't cry about it
i didn't think about it
and then when i had that moment in the
scene where i just am focused on like
uber focused on it it just snapped and
that's how ptsd works it shows up when
you least expect it and i mean that's
how i kind of grow up too like you gotta
white knuckle it like hey man keep it in
ever my mom calls me like the dad or the
fat you've turned into the youngest but
somehow you've become like
that in the family i'm like ah man i
don't know how the hell that happened
but okay great you know like that's a
responsibility
you know and
sometimes you gotta just white knuckle
shit for everybody you just gotta just
keep it and bury it and just bury it and
then bury it again
try to come out of there
you jump on it like you're sitting on
you're still like sitting on a suitcase
trying to zip it after putting the hotel
towels in that's exactly right and then
it just comes out it's whack-a-mole
and it makes me think the more i i
realize in ways that i've done that from
you know sexual abuse as a kid or
anything like that i also realized like
it helps me have compassion for um other
people that are just acting wild you
know especially post-pandemic the shit
you see on the internet when you see
people just being wild and like
canceling people that you know are you
know shouldn't have known better or
didn't whatever overreacting right
hysterical reactions if hysterical it's
historical and then i'm like wait a
second all these people on twitter
acting like this like these
these could be people that have trauma
that yeah pushed it down and now it
because it comes out at the worst time
often around people that don't deserve
it and it's going to come out hell or
high water so i think as a species we
have such a we're so um underdeveloped
in terms of the concept of like healing
trauma so that it doesn't continue her
people don't keep hurting people like we
do that definitely in arab culture like
we definitely bury stuff just like
anybody else
and
it's not a buddhist and we have like
we're taught i remember being taught a
very young age like
meditation and you know repeating
certain words and having that
you know having that
outlet to just pray you know your mind
it's not like just pray like the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him said like
this has been prescribed to you it's
like a it's like a medicine
you know like praying five times a day
is a prescription it's not a yes it's
it's mandatory it's like part of the
pillars of islam but the way it's
phrased
it's a medicine
it's a way to relieve your heart and
and your mind
of things you didn't even know you had
in there do you look at this american
kind of
pseudo-obsession it's all kind of
performative with like meditation like
we just discovered meditation like two
years ago
so just annoying and fucking yoga like
get out of here
get out of here this yoga shit like
like shut the fuck up that is so like
it's all borrowed from all these
different religions it's like so
annoying
let me tell you the story about my
teacher he was praying muslim man
scholar
praying at a a at a at a airport he's
just started praying and security comes
over he's like sir
you can't pray here he goes oh no i'm
doing yoga and he goes okay and just
leaves him alone and he continues
the fact that he's like i'm going to
pray i'm going to pray you can't no i'm
actually new to the thing that makes you
fart yeah exactly
oh you're good yeah you're good yeah
yeah he was okay with yoga but he can't
you can't pray here
yeah i have stories from my friends that
like they were praying you know on their
lunch break on set and some people were
like hey why is he doing that here
you're like it's his lunch break he's
praying like
i think they would rather you doing
cocaine and fucking hookers it's true
that is so fascinating to me because
it's
kind of natural to go like oh well
that's not something i believe so it
shouldn't exist at all yeah if i don't
believe it it just shouldn't exist or
the terror management theory of like
wait you have this
religion that works really well for you
you have this medicine and
my ego can't handle right that's i'd
rather stay sick
than have someone else have a better
idea right because we basically unless
we're working really really hard on
ourselves we are recreating our
childhood circumstances right with the
people we're surrounded with and it's
like recreating that neurochemical
cocktail of adrenaline and cortisol or
shame or whatever it is you know i
sometimes would find myself in
relationships with drug addicts and
alcoholics i was like i hate this i hate
drama but i am magnetically attracted to
this feeling the amount of like
attractive women that are like
are attracted to guys who
are addicts
almost makes me want to shoot up you
know what i'm saying like
it's like maybe let's see let's do this
an experiment please pretend i don't
have an addictive personality like
outside of cigarettes and food like i
don't really have
i could do that for a week and see what
happens you know what you could do
start dating like the hottest models on
earth like yeah man it's just like
i don't know
just uh i just did a bunch of coke in
l.a didn't test it for fentanyl yeah
maybe you should swing by and rescue me
for real
what is that there's a couple so
interesting there's a couple things
there but what you could do is you could
just say you're recently sober and it
would be a lie oh because that we also
like the guys that they're they're the
bad decisions are in the past yeah yeah
that's hot you know what i mean like
you're so i'm struggling every day
to do blow but if you just suck my dick
i won't need to do that cocaine
i mean yeah
guys no pun intended i just if you we
can't have a threesome with your friends
i really feel like i have to do math
i'm gonna throw myself off of the
building i am i'm gonna do it i think
what it is especially with hot girls is
the only thing that is um
sort of more important to an addict's
brain than the hot girl is the drug
so to a drug addict a hot girl is a 10
when there's no cocaine around but when
cocaine's around she's a four yeah you
know just because i'm gonna i'm gonna
pick the cocaine every time so i think
hot girls are so
not used to being ignored or having
something chosen over them that there's
this
chase of i'm going to make him love me
as much as he loves that drug are you
it's like a you're jealous of the drug
that he's loved so much more than you
know and i remember i dated this drug
addict once who um he said straight up
because i was like you know you think
sex or the best blow job or something is
going to get them to love you and he
just said he's like i've done heroin
it's like a thousand orgasms like
there's nothing you can do
that's gonna feel bad you know this is
like the best ad for heroin right there
have you
nutted repeatedly and
just felt like it wasn't enough
we'll just do heroin at the same time we
can't help you with that oh god forbid i
also want to ask because i am someone
that um kind of identifies as an
accident i've been told i was an
accident i was told i was an accident a
hundred percent i'm just gonna put this
in my mouth please do it and you also
can smoke in here and if um you can sit
outside if you want um you make me look
like a loser oh my god don't say that i
hate cigarette smoke that much oh no i'm
cool
that was a good that was nice i liked it
again that's how you know how cool you
are you tell people yeah they're cool
she would have done great in your high
school in houston yeah i told you
exactly who was
it
but i also think there's i already felt
like when i saw he's the six or six of
six children yeah i'm like does he know
he's a mistake he must oh mom told me
yeah yeah mom told me i took it so
personal but she was actually trying to
give me a compliment
my mom would always say surprise yes you
were surprised
yeah that's what she was saying she was
like i didn't expect
isn't there something though kind of
like magical about i feel like when you
are a whatever mistake or was we're born
because a lot of times women get
pregnant right after they have
a child because they think they can't
like what are the chances and they're
like ah let's try this out the stitches
just healed like
you know what i mean like oh immediately
i've been using your butt in your mouth
let's see let's give it a run
let's give it a you know it's been five
kids we're done let's see if this thing
even works anymore and then there you go
so that's a lot of fun but i feel like
on some level i knew like i always
overcompensated i always felt like i
needed to be perfect i always felt like
i couldn't add any stress to the house i
couldn't have any needs i became a
chronic self-depriver because i feel
like they
and just kids know everything we know
everything you know and even if they
never said it switched to me i always
was like i feel like they hadn't they
didn't know i was on the way i always
feel like i was overwhelming everyone i
always feel like they weren't prepared
for me you know and then that makes us
have this work ethic okay i'm going to
be perfect i swear i'm going to earn my
place here like i swear um you really
can smoke um no no it's fine you want to
just hold it okay this will help i'm not
going to okay oh please do an evacuation
i'll smoke too
no beautiful women
beautiful women love addicts
come on
i want to i want to i'm just like go for
it go for it here no i didn't wash my
hair today is that okay that's fine this
is like all natural tobacco so you don't
have here's gonna be your ash is that my
a versace trash can fancy in here is it
really
this is the dopest shit character in the
show would sell out of his car that's a
hundred percent something else
that's so good right i got that on etsy
yeah
so it's oh that's it yeah no that's not
yeah
okay i'm gonna do it you're gonna do it
i'm so sorry
i'll do it with you if it makes you feel
better when that's how codependent i am
first yeah when people when andrew
shelton's on the show i would i hate
smoking a lot i love smoking but i try
not to be a smoker so when other people
smoke it makes me so excited yeah i
don't give a fuck man i want to smoke
all the time like i'm definitely trying
to quit at the end of the year
do you feel like american spirits is
going to
have to change this at some point
no i hope they don't
this doesn't seem a little dicey it's
definitely nice for sure redskins i mean
that felt long overdue this is i'm just
waiting
i think i would stop smoking if they did
that so
something about like i trust the natives
do we feel like the natives are do we
feel like this isn't some white guy
named earl i feel like earl rockefeller
started this brand it feels
most of them don't say made with organic
tobacco up top there's only two that are
actually organic tobacco one in the
other blue oh interesting so everything
else is like i just feel like whoever
got rich off lando lakes and angelima
syrup probably made this yeah 100
there's like
and why do i think it's like a healthy
cigarette it feels like it has that's an
american spirit feeling this is the
healthiest of all healthy cigarettes
for real i mean
it's not great when i was a kid in dc we
would smoke cools with a k
let me tell you something the first
cigarette average menthol was an
unfiltered camel
unfiltered camel cigarette was the first
one i had and you've had a raspy voice
ever since and then how do you when you
have an idea or have an experience or
put something together how do you decide
this is something i'm gonna put in the
show or this is something i'm gonna do
on stage
um i never had like a moment where i was
just like i want to save this or save
that i just get it all out yeah put it
all out there i don't give a shit we'll
create more and also the
you know my family story
and my experience
there's so much
to unpackage yeah
that especially with the eight episode
series it's like so hard
to just
space everything out yeah and there was
so much i mean like i have
probably over 200 index cards and like
stories
whether it be like flashback origin
stories or
things that i've experienced in america
or traveling the world without a
passport or whatever they are i just
keep jotting them down and i have them
like
on index cards like okay this word and i
remember the story i think it goes two
ways it seems like when you have a
really traumatic childhood you either
remember everything or you like
disassociated and like i don't remember
any like kind of i have to i do this
like emdr thing where people try to like
jog your memory to remember stuff but
like i really it seems like you had such
a clear understanding of what was going
on
even as a kid do you think also about
that that is a unique not uniquely but i
think it's uniquely american to have the
privilege of almost blocking out what's
happening to you because you're
maybe for the most part it's safer in
general just when you know the idea that
you're in the spider flight state at
such a young child you had to be so i
think it's a combination of a few things
there's this thing called
autobiographical memory which is so
fascinating where people remember every
single day of their life
every single day what they wore what
they ate what they felt what they did
the day before well autobiographical
memory they remember every the
photographic is different but for
regular people like if you have a
traumatic experience like if you just
smack the shit out of me right now sure
i'll never forget it right you know what
i'm saying look yeah well because i'd
film it for content and it would be a
lot yes we're gonna sell out
let's go this will be the scripted one
you would you i would absolutely
remember that for the rest of my life if
i stub my toe you you're not going to
forget that oh this fucking table did
this did this to me right and our brain
is just designed to survive and hold it
in our hips really hard but i remembered
everything like when i recreated the
house that we fled from in kuwait
my mom was just in tears because i
remembered everything and then we had
some pictures some references but there
was certain things like the plants the
the record player the you know my dad
was a telecommunications engineer and he
was so ahead of it with electronics like
he had like a phone in the 60s you know
and put over his shoulder my mom would
tell me like he had that big ass like
it looked like an engine hanging off of
his shoulder it was a phone he had all
that so i remembered all those pieces
and remember what the street looked like
the colors the just they had like almost
a photographic memory associated with
that there's a few things like that for
me and there's not many
thankfully i do i do think that i deal
with things pretty decently
and
boy that breath were squeaked my voice
just squeaked my lungs it was like well
maybe i need to quit smoking i just that
was wild i did not know that i was like
i've never had that
i was waiting for um one of those uh
catching up to me
you know your horses are out front now
you know old time movies when like uh a
tumbleweed will go by yeah that was it
you just burped
i just got a hot flash like shit what am
i doing to myself
i'm getting anxious give me another
cigarette
it was like
in the old west
that's the beginning of something we
should stop that immediately
did we just participate in your rock
bottom yeah i think so i think so so
what we did literally i'm having a hot
flash like what the fuck was that oh do
you want water no i'm good i'm good i'm
good are you sure no i'm positive yeah
it's okay i don't disagree yes
i think you are not a reliable narrator
i was doing it great all of a sudden i
just
it's like what the fuck was that i don't
know
like probably enrique love would
definitely help some smelling salts i
don't know something did you have some
vicks vape
though dude
dude i grew up on vicks my mom every
night before bed put vicks under our
nose said it was this is preventative
but what you people don't know about
vixx and aphra and all this stuff it
comes very addictive oh it does if you
use it all the time then you're
congested if you you know that's right i
use it my whole life like afrin if you
look like afron exactly yeah yeah you
can't you have and then the vic spray
just to clear your sinuses right and i
would wear vicks every night before bed
even to college like i was addicted to
it i loved it right before bed guys
would be like it was so gross
and uh everyone over here little mama
let me get some of that little vix
please just get some of that vicks the
little tingle egg that shit will tingle
like feels like i'm having a threesome
but
it feels like somebody else is touching
my balls while i'm having sex with you
that's a good way to get a blow job from
the sick girls put vicks right above
your dick and be like
you want to be clear of your
we now take a break from
uh the episode with mo ammer to tell you
a little bit about my tour announcements
uh just this uh saturday september 24th
i'll be in charlottesville virginia at
the paramount theater and then i'm doing
a bunch of clubs this fall uh to work on
the new hour this tour is called the i
club you tour because i club you october
21-23 i'm in san jose i'm going to be in
kansas city november 3rd at the prairie
brand casino resort that sounds like it
is
outside of kansas city
campus
kansas i used to hear ads for prairie
brand casino resort on the radio when i
was driving to school prairie brand
cause band whatever casino resort
november 17th to 19th i'm going to be in
sacramento i'm going to be at the
punchline november 25th then i'm going
to go to phoenix stand up live oxnard
california and then valentine's day next
year i'll be in irvine california
let's do it for a word from our sponsor
help now why do you love therapy so much
i love it because i can talk about you
you know you can do that like just
gossip for
free signed an nda you know
how many people would sign up to talk
shit about me for free with you i signed
an nda she's not possible she's
she's famously said that nbas are fake i
was gonna say had you if she's if you
would unmute my instagram feed you would
know that i for weeks i am on the
bandwagon of nda's art basically means
nothing ironically my better health
counselor insisted that i mute your
instagram stories
okay promote her
that is she is awesome um no for me it's
just like i think
we tend to over share with our friends
and it makes our relationships toxic
it's like you know there are certain
things you don't want to talk to about
the people you know because then they're
never going to let you live it down and
your friends are going to remember when
you talk smack about the romantic
interest and then they'll never forget
it that's the problem is anytime anybody
comes to me for like a relationship like
with relationship quandaries uh my
advice is only just break up with them
yeah which isn't productive it's
probably not the right thing to say if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help is a great option it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online get matched with the
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapists anytime
when you want to be a better problem
solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com whitney today to get 10
off your first month i just want to get
healthy enough in therapy to be able to
fire my therapist if i need to that's
betterhlp.com
whitney back to mo momo
i remember when i was in college getting
up like going to like a coffee shop wawa
or whatever in philadelphia and going in
and i hadn't washed my face i was in
pajamas and someone goes is that vixx
and i was like okay this is i'm not
getting away with this shit is so potent
um i love that though it's so good i
kind of a fan of it i know i love it
i like i like people that have like
little quirks like that it's just i like
it what are your little quirks do you
have any that like
i'm sure i can't pinpoint them right now
i'm just organized like i really like
things in their space like it just
really drives me crazy if they're not
like
like a room being dirty or like when i
get to the hotel even if i'm there for
like four days doing on tour
i'll make sure to unpack and i every
everything is in its own
same right like i have like little muji
pouches pants and thing underwear socks
everything has even the shoes
like the big thing for me is just like
shoes and you see it in my shower
constantly like this these are brand new
shoes so i just like feel okay wearing
them in the house can i just ask you
about the shoe thing like guys and shoes
i have a bunch of friends that are the
sneaker heads it's like
do you have your out you're going out
shoes and you're i know i'm gonna stay
in shoes cause i've made the mistake of
stepping on a new i didn't like you
i feel like we need a like a sticker or
something that's like these are new
yeah you let me you know what i'm saying
i'm not gonna hug you if they're new
it's almost like heads have always had
the six feet rule well i don't have the
same attachment as they do to it like
i just
well thankfully i'm in a position where
people are just sending me shoes all the
fucking time like it's not a problem
my air
are you buying them i'm a yeezy guy i'm
a easy guy all the way i wear them the
most comfortable fucking shoe like kanye
hacked the whole system
he just made like designer orthopedics
the guy's a fucking genius like who why
would you wear anything else that will
be in style dunk the basketball in his
life outsold jordan howe designer
orthopedics that's how and by the way
fucking amazing shoes that will always
stay in style because they've never been
in style ever exactly exactly he's just
like from a different planet did you see
the documentary the netflix documentary
on him yes
the way that he said this was incredible
and changed my life the way when he's
talking to some of the designers and he
says like everything is has to be
intentional yeah like everything has to
be purposeful and intentional instead of
just slap this here and slap this here
you know it's that going the extra mile
that obsessiveness is what i think makes
great yeah no absolutely he has a really
great sense of humor i was
in the room when he gave dave the
unreleased he gave chappelle he's
unreleased but like took him off of his
feet
and gave him today he's like what size
you wear and they wore the same size
shoe
12's and he took him off his feet and
gave him to dave he goes and he put him
on dave and he starts feeling on the tip
of the shoe he's like you see that
see that this gpt technology like what's
that he was getting pussy technology
right here
it was just like i just saw this very
sweet moment where
he literally gave the shoes off of his
feet to his friend
because he had nike's on he's like take
them off
and he gave it to him and then kim was
like texting to get him another pair of
shoes and for the rest of the time like
at the show he's walking around just
with socks
because he wouldn't put on dave she's
like dave you could have my they was
trying to give him his shoes he was like
i don't want those
you're like those are the lemons those
are the lemons but it's just so sweet to
see somebody like do that
to his friend for his friend like no i
want you to have these and he just takes
them off of his feet and gives it to him
it was just really really bad that is
really touching but also billionaires
can do that
yes absolutely billionaires can
absolutely do that but most won't yeah
that's true that is true no it won't it
just tells like his upgrade to his
spirit his heart and yes yes and we all
yeah this sounds you know maybe a little
nuts when i say it i know i get people
get mad at me sometimes because they
think i'm defending problematic
comedians or something but i just like
to really parse out and going like no
matter how much you hate a comedian no
matter how much you hit an artist no
matter how mad you are at kanye for
whatever he said when he was having you
know uh obviously
psychologically struggling like we were
bullying someone yeah with major
psychological struggles sure no matter
how much you hate a comedian artist
they still get up every morning trying
to make someone they have never bring
joy to someone they have never met
whether they don't know how the per the
people voted they don't know how our
only
goal is to make a stranger
have joy and we get it wrong sometimes
and we don't always deliver and that's
not you know things change in comedy is
fashion but it's like you know any even
even problematic tv shows and in in
romantic comedies this sort of like new
trend of like friends but can we agree
the friends was a little racist can we
agree that you know uh uh you know these
romantic comedies gave us toxic ideas of
what relationships should look like it's
also like whatever the guy that wrote
that romantic comedy that you think is
such a sexist asshole he was just not
loved by his parents he had trauma he's
just trying to get love and make
strangers laugh and you know what i mean
it's like sometimes it doesn't also they
bought it hollywood bought it and made
it like if you want to just like nitpick
on every single thing like just look at
the history of hollywood like built on
the back of a toddler named shirley
temple right built on the shoulders of a
child you know what i'm saying like this
is the kind of thing like wait what are
we doing yes yes like everything has
become so inverted we're like hey hey
respect this respect that i could wear
what i i could do that and then and then
you have like a hyper sexualized world
where a kid can fucking google anything
and just be just introduced to all this
pornography all this stuff but it's like
hey we got to respect women this is what
we're going to do and then all of a
sudden porn is like completely open and
you can do that and you know most of
these women don't like i'm sure that the
vast majority don't want to fucking do
this and are put in positions that don't
no pun intended that i don't want to be
in you know like it's just it i just
don't understand what the hell is going
on yeah i really don't it's like an
inverted reality there's a great talk
this woman um gail dines uh talks about
this and there's a great book called
porn nation that i think is my life
too special to go i i i talked a lot
about porn but um is that it used to be
like you know even when you were growing
up probably like it is normal for a 10
11 12 year old boy to want to see
boobies that's normal that's healthy
whether it's like you know the a bathing
suit catalog or you know best case
scenario you find your dad's playboy and
you see boobies and you know big bush
when i came to america
i was so innocent and the preservation
of my innocence of children was so
important from where i came from and i
ended up in houston and when i was 10
years old we're in an apartment complex
they weren't there too long thankfully
and this kid was like let's go uh you
know
something about playboy that's all i
heard but i was so innocent i was like
oh we're just going to go play that's
all i think we're a bunch of boys and
we're going to go play
and we get to his house and then all of
a sudden like why are we in the closet
it's weird and then he takes out his
dad's playboy and i just freaked the
fuck out ah
what is this titties oh my god like i
just i was so shy and mortified but i
was
also happy but i'm sorry but just very
confused
this is horrible they have you this is
horrible
i want to say
yes
yeah it was just really weird for me it
was just like scary because i just
never was introduced to anything like
that
ever that is wild but now that's best
case scenario and then you figure it out
and whatever but now if if that was if
you were nine years old today you go you
know i'm gonna just go on google and
google boobies you know but when you
google boobs or sex
fisting comes you know i can't do it and
then that would be someone's first
introduction they think that's what sex
is that shouldn't be the first thing you
see
insane you know so i've watched porn in
like over seven plus years i don't know
how long it's been now i just like
completely cut it out of my life just
wasn't was there it wasn't never like i
had an addiction or i didn't have like
oh i gotta do this together no it was
just like ridiculous like what am i
doing this is i'm having first of all
i'm really imaginative person like i
don't need
like that's what i do like i create
scenarios i love the idea you're
watching porn you're like i could do
this i could do that mine is better this
storyline
you're writing for writers and you're
performers you're always like this is
the bet you had one single there's no
coverage on this
one
you didn't come in dirty over this would
have been great cover up the bruises so
this is too much you know i just i just
was it was a moment where i was just
like looking through like fucking trying
to watch a movie on netflix like i
couldn't make it like what am i doing
what am i doing this could be done in 30
seconds like what the fuck am i doing
and then i was just at home just
channel surfing and then next you know
it's like romantic comedy comes on as
just a regular kiss happens and i was
just excited
i was like oh i'm a kid again this is
fucking awesome he's just like cleansing
whatever bullshit was that i was
watching i feel like i can't be the pr
i've talked about porn so much because i
think it i think
you know it
i never want to be the person who's like
porn's bad because it's bad for men and
women some of it not all of it whatever
um i don't want to get too black and
white about it but like when a guy says
it it's like you know that is always so
healing because it's like it hurts men
yeah you know almost probably maybe even
like
women have always been objectified way
before porn when people say that like
the sex robots are coming they're
objectified women that's already been
fucking happening you know what i mean
and uh actually
men treat the women that are obsessively
objectified way better than actual
objects have you seen the way that men
treat porn stars at like porn
conventions it's like
they treat the quote objectified women
actually better yeah and then they treat
actual women and robots
you know they're very delicate with them
the men that have robots and sex robots
and stuff so that's just an interesting
irony but just the idea that like guys
it's harder and harder to enjoy set like
you're making sex worse for yourself
when it actually happens it was worse
for me it was absolutely worse when i
was watching porn it's not
it just was different my whole
relationship with it was just different
it wasn't it wasn't healthy it just i
knew something was wildly off and i just
can't do this anymore it's probably
better for me and also like instagram is
porn enough for me
like it's all i need like how much do i
need there's like string bikinis now
it's not even a bikini there's like a
lace necklace going down her ass crack
this is all i need like this is fine
she's making her ass like bridal laundry
this was just like i'm learning more
about your kids i'm just it ca it comes
and i click on one like hey whoa it pops
up and then all of a sudden it's all i
want to see i gotta like buffer i gotta
like start looking up cat videos just to
calm it down you know like for real this
shit was weird just one thing he's like
whoa and i indulge just for a second and
it's a whole fucking situation now with
my ig like i gotta filter this out i
gotta look at keeps getting hurt i gotta
watch kids getting hurt or something for
a hot minute just to kind of change this
up yeah this is wild so it's like i
don't need more than that it is yeah
we're desensitizing ourselves i also
seem like you seem like i hope this
doesn't come off wrong because i know
that this is a tricky word for people
but you you strike me as someone i'm
very proud to be a sensitive person the
word empath and i don't mean it as
sensitive as in like reactive and like
emotional i mean like you absorb people
very much comedians we absorb people's
energy
part of the reason i can't live too far
into the city or new york i walk three
blocks and i like feel
sadness i feel a heaviness like i just
feel like i take on people's energy and
when i'm watching porn i'm like
i don't know she it feels like she's i
think you know i don't know maybe she
should call her dad and yeah
i just i start like telling you too much
i read a lot about it and i started
reading about it and just
so much and so many injections and
medicine they have to take and and like
to maintain an erection for they have to
do like most of them don't feel anything
anymore like it's so fucking weird i was
like yo i can't touch this thing and i
am a sensitive person like i am
sensitive people's energy yeah that's
what it is i'm very sensitive to it i
can feel it that's why like i you know
if it's not right it's not right and
that's what makes great comedians
because you feel something's weird it's
an antenna it's an antenna we all have
an antenna some people's antennas more
sensitive it can pick up a lot more than
most
so it's just like i do have that where
and i and i have proof where i've left
a space and some horrible shit has
happened
minutes after i left like it's happened
a lot of my life actually and azar who i
traveled the world with doing stand-up
he uh i would always tell him like man
i'm assessing the situation right now
it's not good we should leave right now
i would always say that he's like you're
always saying this to me and he just
started getting to my face about it he's
like bro you're always right though like
it it's a high percentage of where
you're
you're batting a high percentage here
like you really get it and just being in
tune to what's around you and like even
after performance and you have all these
people people people forget like
they could project onto you like the
evil eye is actually a real thing
there's a reason why it's existed for so
long like there's energy coming at you
whether it's jealousy or or
they're into you or not into you or
whatever it is want something that's a
thing you know people forget like you
walk around outside you grab a towel you
wipe your face you can get shit on if
you have filth all over you like there's
like this dark spot on this towel the
same thing can have there's spiritual
illnesses that can be projected upon you
it happens like an emotional contagion
and washing there's a reason why you
feel so good after you wash yeah and my
teacher taught me he's like yeah after
you perform or do that you have so many
thousands of people looking at you at
any given night you go home you should
cleanse you should like take a shower
you should like meditate you should have
time for yourself and do that
probably a lot of people do that
subconsciously they don't even know what
they're doing but they know they feel
better there's something about water
something about like purifying yourself
and just getting into a right space
after you had so many people engaged
people want your energy to hey can i
take a picture hey what's going on ah
man big fan oh you know that and you
have to like pay attention to them i
want i'm interested but you're not just
getting that you're i i got sort of a
different thing but it's
dude you
saved my life i mean you i imagine you
get such heavy stuff of oh this is a
story of my yeah so you have people it's
not like all right cool man yeah yeah
it's like
you know i think that when you've chosen
the path of radical honesty and i'm
gonna share my trauma with the world to
help heal you're also gravitating people
that are coming up to you in tears and
you're just like
i
have so little to give but i want to
hold this space for you what's my
responsibility to you and it's taken me
a long time to realize like i can just
sit and i can just listen and i can like
say thank you for sure and that's enough
yeah because i we have such finite
energy and this is to me when i see
comedians that are you know sick and
dealing with depression and anxiety and
stuff like that it's like we're so
grateful to finally have fans and
finally people appreciate what we do but
we try so hard to give so much back
sorry i have like a pube in my eyeball
um yeah what is happening it's a good
monday this is not it's this is you know
i feel so guilty because my hair
extensions are russian are they yes they
i'm
um but uh but yeah being able to go like
i don't have to feel guilt if i can't
meet and greet every single person but i
also really fucking want to you know i
think that it's like um i have a
muhammad ali rule about this make time
for everybody you punch him in the face
oh yeah
someone makes you close
too pretty not
i try available try like it's really
really important to me because he's
such a big
influence in my life and i just
see him as just
somebody who's done it on the highest
level where in his sport but also
maintain his integrity as
who he is and what he believed and i
mean look at all his interviews nobody
talks like that on television yeah while
he's fucking amazing so i i and and i've
all i heard about him and i know is
uh daughter maymay who gave me the
picture of my like a a picture of mom
and ali who's doing this in a photograph
on top of the mountain you see it in
episode eight
and there was a picture of me as a child
doing the same thing it just made me
feel so we put it we cut it into the
show
and you can't like unless you're looking
for it you won't really see it
but it's just some somebody really
looked up to maintain his integrity
maintained what he believed in
was so steadfast and everything and then
like learn little magic tricks so he can
tank kids when they walk up to him
like he was just amazing i think i
forgot who was telling the story
um trying to
who's the boss who's the who's the lead
in that while you're thinking uh about
this there was an open mic comic who
used to do a joke like 15 years ago when
i went to a bruce springsteen concert
and tony danza was there and i looked at
you tony and i was like dang who's the
boss yeah
no but tony danzo i was thinking about
he saw muhammad ali signing autographs
and this and that and he he
you know he whispers about his ear like
you want me to get you out of here
something like that or
uh you know like you okay he's like why
are you doing this
and muhammad ali whispered in his ear
goes i'm trying to get into heaven
oh
just want to get into heaven
that's it and he was just like whoa
just put everything in perspective the
guy did not care man made time forever
well here's what it is to me it's the
antidote for all of the resentment and
the anger that not only comedians have
but everyone has now which is
no one wants us to say anything
everyone's trying to censor us and
everyone hates comedians and everyone
thinks
and then you talk to people and you're
like none of that's true this is to me
it's also collecting the data that
inspires me and keeps me courageous and
keeps me going and keeps me out of the
narrative of like people don't like me
because i'm a girl i'm this i'm the
twitter and whatever because people from
twitter don't come to shows they're not
comedy fans you know so it reminds me
like
what comedy fans are like and in general
in this moment where we all have so many
excuses to be misanthropic and isolated
everyone's
racist everyone's an asshole everyone's
a piece of garbage just go talk to three
people every day feedback from the
people that are your contributions after
shows i have
i haven't been great at this but just
because it just required yeah i heard
about this but just no just talking to
everyone is just so hard especially when
you have two shows a night so i usually
come out after the second show and i let
it just kind of wind down as much as
possible it's just so much energy and i
as a rule basically when i'm on the road
i'm freestyling
my sets you know
i'm like working it out and just like
freestyling
um
like hours at a time just trying to get
the shit together especially when i
first go out just like all these ideas
everywhere
and then i just like just go up there
and just talk bro see what happens how
often do you go back to the middle east
to perform
um
usually like a once a year because i've
been doing shows there since like 2006
i was like one of the first the first
thing arab american ever performed in
egypt
as a comedian that was crazy and then i
went back every year and then the
revolution happened
and i obviously couldn't go back to
egypt specifically but i go i go pretty
often the last time was in 2019
you know and then depend i was supposed
to do shows after that no i went back i
did chosen dubai in october of 2021.
this is mine
i can't believe it's in here so
when i
12 13 years ago i went and performed in
dubai i went to i performed dubai a
couple times but ahmed ahmed put
together that tour it was me and
sebastian maniscalco and i think kirk
fox and tommy davidson like just random
groups we would go over there right
right and i just want to tell you this
one story because it's so embarrassing
but i think that
i won't be able to make eye contact
after so let's let's go for it so um i'm
going to uh perform in dubai at the time
you know
my concept of that area is not only what
i've seen in you know racist movies and
you know that kind of bullshit and
post-9 11 and everything that happened
you know in america but also like
you know this there's an absence also of
knowing really much of anything you know
i'm going but also everything everybody
said to me before going over i also was
like oh well dubai it's fine
and then everyone's like well you're
gonna go do comedy over there like are
you gonna what are you gonna be okay
like
you know and like you had to learn to
bob and weave and like
everyone was so which the irony and
looking back is that people do that
about
you know everywhere they're you know
uh extremely racist in that area because
like i'm going to florida they're like
well watch for the gators and watch for
the race you know it's like everyone
makes you got a lot more to worry about
in florida than you ever do in dubai one
of the safest places in the world and
also medina saudi arabia the safest
place for women on planet earth dubai
according to like an independent
travel insurance website by white people
tell you like medina specifically in
saudi arabia is the safest place
on planet earth for women fascinating
so dubai shut the fuck up dubai i
literally was like uh
uh you know i came prepared i'm like do
i need to bring bear spray like the way
people were talking to me about it i i'm
walking around alone not only
was did no one even flirt guys wouldn't
even make eye contact with me and i
started being like am i what oh yeah
that's disrespectful like a man's not
just going to look at you you know so
there was that and then also yeah dubai
is the safest place it's like disneyland
you know but going over there i was sort
of like trying to figure out this
moment of okay i'm performing dubai they
said they're like whitney cummings is
the first female comedian to ever
perform in the middle east i'm like
that's hilarious you know there were
many many many yeah
that either weren't
you know so i'm sort of fascinated by
females most of the singers like thumb
was like
an icon she is an icon it was an icon um
in the middle east phenomenal like sing
a poetry she would like have these like
45 minute songs like wow it was just
like stories to the point where like
wars would stop with she was singing
live on the radio it's just like
just to explain how important she was to
the cause can you say her name one more
time m
i don't even know how you spell that
phonetically um oh i see
she always used you
hold a handkerchief in her hand when she
sang but she's an icon absolute icon
we would never like i don't know when
that would have come up for us unless
you're in like middle eastern but
yeah it doesn't happen like that doesn't
happen it is very rare
for a female comedian to perform in the
middle east
not anymore yeah but definitely still
like whoa you know it's a thing yeah
that happens and they do look away it's
like an islamic thing to it's a muslim
thing to kind of respect and not you
know hoggle a woman like oh just look at
her down the street and i'm not supposed
to do it thinking i'm at my hottest i'm
like catching
nothing the more they resist the
probably the hotter you are
yeah
[Laughter]
so i wrote about this um in my book it's
like the final chapter of my book
because it's the most embarrassing story
and i thought like maybe people don't
finish it you know uh they'll miss this
part because i went to one of the malls
in dubai i'm kind of like walking around
alone just exploring you know my brother
ended up living in dubai for like 10 15
years we've spent a lot of time over
there
yeah he works in the middle east like he
um for a bank in the middle east and so
uh uh i see these i see many women in
the garb the full garb older women and
you know i'm like that tracks makes
sense okay whatever i've you know
don't know enough about it but i do know
that if you're older like
that ship sailed or whatever and then i
see these younger girls they're in like
short shorts and tank tops like you know
20 year old girls at with heels the
purses everything oh yeah yeah american
neck down or whatever like would make
perfect sense in a mall a mall of
america and then had the hijab on right
so my brain
ignorant
american doesn't know shit does not know
the least i'm like
i have to help them
yeah
like they're young the older women like
that i'm not going to convince them you
know they're americanized they probably
speaking they look at you and they're
like we need to help her i yeah oh no
oh that's oh it was so bad
i went up to them because i'm like i'm
like should i could i get extra flights
home like oh how could i get them like
are they okay you gotta get them out
yeah are they being trafficked
the opposite
meanwhile the entire time when you're
walking around the middle east you're
just getting so hot and sunburned you're
like i wish i just had a thin
like if there was like a thin veil
yeah just put over your skin yeah
exactly well that would be amazing you
know
and so yeah we forget about like the sun
protection of it and all that but so i
went up to them and i just went for it i
was like you know the full american
arrogance thinking i'm like a hero
and i'm also trying to get jokes before
the show i would love to have seen that
to be a fly on a wall to see this thing
happen it was
yeah you know me a little bit yeah
speech i'm not it's hard to make me like
speechless yeah it's where i don't have
some kind of comeback i was
so i go up to them and i was like hey
girls like i'm my name is when i'm you
know from america they're like yeah we
know i mean like yeah and i was like i
just want to make sure like you're
okay
like i don't like it was literally like
uh
you know in airports where it says like
human trafficking called this number
like i didn't have a plan so funny and
they literally like looked at me and i
was like
like didn't say anything so i'm like oh
they don't speak english i was like i
america
me
and they're like well actually whitney
they just were letting me finish because
they're like oh no go this happens to us
three or four times a day by american
women so they're like we just want to
they're like um so here's the deal we
are not oppressed uh we actually think
that women in america are oppressed
because your appearance is your only
value and you have one of the highest
plastic surgery rates in the world and
the highest eating disorder rates and we
do not define ourselves through our body
and our appearance that's what you guys
do so we choose to do this for this this
and this reason i was like
you've been brainwashed yeah yes
that's existing
yeah so now that no one's around
like it's a form of protection like it's
a form of also a protection aside from
that
it's like it's a conserving yourself so
you don't have the issue of like
being looked at stalked whatever this
whole idea of like yeah but men should
control themselves well some of them
obviously cannot you know and they
should absolutely i agree with that
there's no doubt
but this is like really tricky waters
the fact that you're just wearing pants
where it just goes into your butt and it
just shows the shape yeah people are
going to look bro just even if it's not
a child
it's distracting to women too yes women
check out women too yeah for sure
exactly you know so it's like now we're
americans are slowly catching up to it
you you go you go into a coffee bean in
l.a
full pajamas flip-flops hat you're like
that's doing the same thing right it is
just
yeah jeremy
now it's like biker shorts and like bra
sports bras right that's like the thing
now yeah but it was this such a profound
moment and for me it's it's embarrassing
that it got to this you know and um
you know but i just was like oh is the
only way to heal this for people to
actually visit here like there was this
amazing uh a friend of mine yashar ali
is um iranian and he posted the other
day uh it was like a juxtaposing what
people think iran looks like versus iran
it looks like new york city but what
people think iran looks like it was like
a
you know just like a box or something
you know
but it's important to have people
thinking this way so you can drive
political objectives right
you can dehumanize some people and make
them less hand then you can just go
pummel the shit out of them right i mean
this happened when i was touring in
south africa before i left everyone was
scared
like don't go oh my god this is gonna
happen south africa it was like 2007 i
think
and he they were just like don't go this
is so it's so dangerous in south africa
and it got in my head but it did i was
like get out of here you know i'll be
fine and we land i landed joburg
and with the driver we pull up to the
hotel i'm getting out of the car to grab
my luggage and then all of a sudden
explosions like what the fuck even the
driver was like oh shit and we just get
under the car we're on the side
breathing heavily
[Music]
more explosions i was like oh shit they
were right they were so fucking right
and also here caught all right it was a
great take it was fucking filming a
movie downstairs i think it was like
blood diamond
filming down the street i was like oh
god damn they got me
you know not the the movie incredible
not the movie shoot but these bastards
totally put this in my head i bought
into it
and this is embarrassing i fled war this
is nothing well yeah it's also like when
people can go there it's dangerous it's
like where a high school in america yeah
exactly high school elementary school
yeah it's disgusting but that's what is
south side of chicago i call it
chiropractic say that but i think it's
important it's time we're like
challenging what you've been taught and
what you've been indoctrinated with it's
like why do we think that
the you know that is more dangerous than
the school down the street if we
humans i guess we and this is what i
want to ask you before i let you go is
just like what you've learned about
human nature what we all have in common
in a good way and a bad way of like we
have this incredible ability to tell
ourselves stories that aren't true we
have this incredible ability to eschew
data that is not convenient for what our
narrative is of their bad we're good you
know terror management theory the ernest
becker book has really helped me with
that because i it helps me have
compassion for people that you're like
how could you believe this is true you
know like how could you think that
how can you go don't go to south africa
man this can be really dangerous when
there's shootings in america you know
what how what do our brains um why do
they need to lie to themselves it's
catastrophizing yeah
because
that word changed my life really
it's a psychological term where you just
like project
things into the world where you think oh
my god i'm going to be late uh to this
meeting everybody's going to be waiting
on me i'm going to be in so much trouble
everything's fucking get there you're
the only person there yeah just creating
these scenarios in your mind they're
completely not true and then somehow
like preparing for the worst preparing
for the words you've had the word you've
that was you got that honestly yes and
it's like
through that experience has taught me to
also
not catastrophize like hey man whatever
happens happens like what's written for
you is truly what's written for you i'm
a prime example of that
and just traveling the world i've been
like about 50 countries
and just seeing everybody is the same
everyone's struggling
everyone's trying to figure out their
way
we're all floating on this ball in the
middle of space trying to figure this
shit out everybody has an issue at home
there's something even the ones that are
super happy they're burying something
down
people are the same just speaking
different languages
but still communicate
in a in a really profound way like
i've talked to somebody that we didn't
speak each other's languages at all but
somehow communicate with each other a
woman
no okay well yes i did yeah yeah they'll
also happen
yeah no that happened that happened too
but i also like
i did this thing in durban south africa
which is supposed to be like one of the
most dangerous cities
in south africa it was middle night i
want to go buy cigarettes
and
um the security guard was like don't go
but i buy you the cigarettes don't go i
was like no i'm good i wore the shirt
mostly shirt had eman written in arabic
which means faith
i put on a koofi which is like virtuous
so you know like i'm most in my muslim
uniform right now i'm going out
and i'm going to go by say this after 11
o'clock and i guess like please bruh
don't go he's like begging me i was like
nah man i'm gonna go
just leave me alone i'll be fine
and i left
and i figured out really quickly it's
like i could see why he was telling me
not to go but i just went
and i was so well received like people
were hello and the next thing you know i
was gone for like three hours
ended up hanging out with these guys on
milk crates
in the slums like in a slumy area not
even the full slums but not good
and we were just smoking
the first time i've been
uh
introduced to durban poison which is
like a really well-known
weed
uh strain
i just sat there and smoked weed with
them to like almost two something in the
morning the doorman must have been so
worried the security guard was
mortified i come back he's like
and i'm high as shit like
just like brah what are you doing to me
bro you're my responsibility huh hey
he was just so blown away by it he was
just like wow i think it's like the
energy you put out is really important
that's it
and you can't just roll in like i didn't
go to that neighborhood with my rolex
and you know flossing with my new shoes
i know i just went as me
stripped down
and just beat my there's nothing what
are you going to steal you're going to
kill me what what are you going to take
from me you have nothing and it's also
like this is and it's you know we'll
talk about another time if you're
interested in the equine therapy stuff
and that's why for me working with prey
animals that's what helped me understand
like the energy that you are putting out
is you know
seventy percent of communication is
non-verbal and when we're afraid for
ourselves no people just interpret as
fear and fear feels like anger so that
you're walking through with anger and
they're like who's the fuck is this guy
yeah you know what i mean so then you're
actually that fear is creating the exact
thing you're afraid of having you know
like it's amazing when you just like
dislodged a memory that i've had and
this is all like started like my
grandfather did this to me i was
five years old
and i'm at my uncle's house
and this snake
is coming at me and i just as a kid
would
scream you know
and my grandfather
just with all the precision comes up
just no hesitation grabs a snake
puts it like right here
he's like you afraid of this it's
nothing and he taps my brain like this
he goes
he goes you have this
you can do anything you want with this
don't be scared think
react
five-year-old i'm like
the snake's like
trying to fucking escape and just
changed everything to me and i held it
he was like here hold it
he's like grab my hand put it right on
the right he's like this is how you
control it and if you use your mind you
understand how these work and then you
release it you don't want to kill it you
release it it's not trying to harm you
it's scared of you more than just way
more scared you just do that and release
it i was like oh
then the other one was with bees i was
like mortified of bees like i was
stinging sting you and it was right
there and it was and my my grandfather
puts his hand in front of it
lets the bee crawl on his hand
and he's calm he's like see
it's fine it doesn't want to hurt you
because if it stings you it dies
but it won't but it's about what energy
you're giving out
if i if i tell it i'm scared of it then
it thinks i'm trying to kill it then
it'll sting you
but if you're there and the whole time
it was just crawling his hand and he put
it on my hand and just crawling man i
was like oh
changed
everything for me
like as far as my relationship with bees
or
anything hornets fuck those things those
things
[Laughter]
of what you just said with the bug of
when
you know you moved here and look i grew
up in dc rough parts of dc you know i
didn't know that
dc virginia i was west virginia moved
around
between places but you know to me it's
i've always had such a
uh
this sounds odd but such a connection to
uh people that are unhoused my dad
always told me you always uh
stop and you always if it's some if you
have a pit in your stomach or someone
seems dangerous don't otherwise this
person doesn't have time to kill you the
narcissism of i'm gonna go out in the
world and i'm worth going to jail for
yeah so when you go out and be like i'm
gonna go in this dangerous area oh you
so you're the one this person's going to
go to jail for yeah so this person you
like you think this person
is like waiting for the narcissism of it
you know these are people that are just
trying to solve their own problems
they're just trying to stay safe
themselves yeah you know
and so always stop and engage with them
whatever but what you learn yeah from
prey animals any time you know anything
you try to control controls you and what
happens with horses what happens with
dogs for the mo so i just put um oh you
didn't meet my dog i have this dog that
is a rhodesian ridgeback pit bull and
everyone is so scared of her so scared
of her and she's the sweetest little
thing but what happens is people come in
they see her and they go
you know
and then
she goes
he's there must be a thread around yeah
and then there's a real reason to be
scared because now she and then he's
like oh fuck and he starts running and
she's like well there's then i gotta
chase this guy obviously he did
something wrong so it's like how we you
know uh allow our fear to let us
hallucinate and project onto other
people and you know that is something
that is is the same with with horses you
know so that's what equine therapy is so
powerful because you're able to have a
mirror held up to the energy you're
giving off when you think you're
protecting yourself you're actually
putting yourself in more danger by
allowing your emotions to control you
and so a horse if it's standing near you
and you're chilling right and uh a
horse's only real reward is tranquility
because they're prey animals they ca
they don't need your food they can eat
grass they're grazers they can get grass
whenever they want so if they're hanging
out with you it means that you are
feeling feelings that will be fun for
them to feel too because they're so
empathic so the goal is i need to get to
a place where my energy feels good to be
around i need to feel the feelings
that's another animal or mammal would
want to feel i can't be like well does
the horse like me and i didn't get my
selfie in like i know what if i i'm
running late and no one wants to be
around that shit so they move away from
you or if you're scared of the horse
since the horse has no intention of
harming you
if you're scared it's like well there
must be a mountain lion around and then
all of a sudden it's scared and it just
becomes this emotional contagion
absolutely and i think something that
with praying meditating these things
where you're able to like check in with
your brain and have a modicum of
awareness of how and go like oh that's
just fear yeah and when fear is present
clarity can't exist
no other emotion can exist
and my brain can go
decide that person's different than me
i'm better than we get drunk on fear and
we fucking hallucinate i also think that
people mis
define what's going on with them they
say like oh it's fear and it's
immediately equals something negative
when it could be something actually very
positive it could be like oh man i'm so
scared right now no it could be
excitement
i'm living my dream i'm backstage at msg
yeah exactly you're just like you're
just you're just feeling something and
you and you equate it with something
negative when actually something
positive and and this again like i mean
dave has had a big part of
a big influence in my life and he's just
taught me all these little gems and he's
just like that's because you know
whenever i started feeling something
heavy and i would sometimes associate it
with something negative he's like no
it's because you care so much
it's about you wanting to to give these
people something so good
and you're just feeling a little anxiety
about that and that's fine
channel that and focus into
something that's really positive and i
heard this quote before too is like
instead of like
letting
fear being your headwind let it be your
tailwind
you said is it fuel yeah use it as fuel
like why
giving into it
so easily to be something so negative
when you can truly like drive through it
and i i think i've done that a lot in my
career but i didn't know i was doing it
totally i didn't know i was like yeah
fucking they feel this way i don't care
i'm still gonna push through they're not
ready for a muslim guy palestinian guy
specifically to have his own show
onto their they will be one day the
story is going to have to be told and
whenever it comes to be time and be
super ready
you know i'm going to have all the rest
about if it's about what when it's about
like being prepared for it too and
sometimes you shoot yourself in the foot
by not being prepared by going this will
never happen yeah so i might as well not
try anyway no it's writing is my saying
the reason it's never gonna happen isn't
because of the muslim thing it's because
you didn't have the script yeah you know
so to me like i was man i would have
jewish comedians that love me and care
for me and still friends to me to this
day would tell me change your name bro
change your name like you you're so
talented
just change your name don't tell him
you're palestinian don't tell him you
must like just change it and then you'll
just get so much work i'm like well this
kind of defeats the purpose of why i got
into this and not the work i'd want not
to be one yeah exactly exactly i could
have been an american sniper totally
like i just don't want to sell out you
could have been in every episode of 24.
you know what i'm saying like i could
have easily done that but that's not
something i'm going to be really proud
of
i want to create a legacy i want to
inspire
kids that come after me like to just be
like oh man this guy did it i can do it
too
and that's something that's really
powerful it wasn't the intention
but i definitely knew that these stories
were important and had space and
whenever it's if they're ready for it
it'll be timely and timeless if milo if
i'm gonna keep the last name cummings
yeah right you're keeping your last name
i didn't get to change that's why i came
to do the podcast
i thought you quit
i did that's why i'm here
four camera shooting yeah
um and then i'm just gonna and i'm gonna
let you go i swear i just i'm i'm
just like i'm gonna talk to you forever
ditto and let's just let's do it um i
always uh uh ask in the podcast
brilliant people that are super
perceptive and been through a lot um
just we're talking about the absence of
fear but also protect yourself and
preserve your time and energy and there
are just be uh there are certain red
flags in life that as you get older and
wiser you're like i just wish i knew at
20. if someone
talks shit about every one of their axes
that's a red flag you know things like
that have you learned in being in
business and running a show in you know
the 50 countries you've been to just
some red flags just in people and
there's someone that worked at an actual
flag store yeah he worked at a flag
store i did yeah we sold red flags
such a weird time what was the question
the question is like red flags and
people where people were just now that
people want a lot from you we can feel
people what's something that makes you
you know what or someone yeah usually
it's about people who are just like very
needy interesting and just like are
takers
whether it be something actual physical
or spiritual they're just takers i need
need need give me give me give me give
me there's like no shame
like no
regard for how you feel or whatever it's
always
really one-sided and that's like the
biggest red flag to me and also i find
with that it's taken me a while to
realize that like
a red flag and someone or
to figure out who someone else is which
we never will
you know we can actually back into it
and just go wait how do i feel when i'm
around this person so i can't it's like
is this person needy is it not i can
talk myself we're comedians i can talk
myself in and out of anything i can
defend a criminal i can but to go oh i
just feel depleted with this person yeah
exactly you know or i just i feel like
i'm hiding things yeah i just don't want
to be around people like that yeah so
just like listening to your gut on that
because i think it's hard especially
especially when i check them like if i
if i at least have a moment with them
and i check them and see if like there's
any movement at all and if if they
manipulate the conversation to be
turning themselves into a victim i'm out
you know you got to help yourself i
can't help you you have got to heal
yourself and talking about your trauma
with other people is not healing your
trauma you're just boring someone else
everyone's got it there's this new thing
where everyone thinks it's cool to just
talk about their trauma all the time do
it with your therapist do it in a
12-step program do it on better help
whatever the promo code winning whatever
it is i don't care but but i think that
people are so excited to like have the
vocabulary and talk about their trauma
now that they're over sharing right and
putting it on other people that are
healing their own shit yeah exactly stop
projecting like fucking work on yourself
you're bombing yeah you're bombing all
the time in life you're bombing not only
are you bombing you're not you're not
even giving out that kind of energy
you're just like
succubus just the fuck i call them ev's
energy vacations vampires okay just
absolute eevees az and i came up with
this like real what we call like the
realness lexicon it's just like meta
communication
and it just helps us communicate about
things that we don't have words for
let's call it like i could be in a
conversation with you and just start
getting on my phone
but there's no word like i need pt any
personal time sorry i'm 100 i'm paying
attention i'm actually 95 with you but
five percent here so i can maintain the
conversation that never happens and
people just sit there and fucking wander
wonder what's going on so there's like
eevee energy vacuum
then there's a we have a term called
dutch nita who's somebody who's wrong
somebody who knows they're in the wrong
somebody refuses to admit that they're
wrong and strong wrong and strong and
they just can't let their ego
let go of this thing and they just have
to be right i call that and then
podcasters
[Laughter]
there's some people that do feel that
way that have good hearts you just
require some kind of effort
to help them see themselves i love
new words for things that the words that
don't exist yeah the situation never
resisted before so my big thing is
energy dollars yeah like how many energy
dollars you have a day like no say you
have 100 energy dollars a day you have
to make sure you're not overspending
your energy dollars you know and then if
someone is like oh do you want to go out
to drink and i'm like oh in my head i'm
like i already spent 80 energy dollars
today i only have 10 more left i have to
go to my spot and i'd have to borrow
from tomorrow so like i don't have any
if you say to someone if you ask me to
like do something and i just go like i
don't have any energy dollars left
it's really hard
i spent all my energy dollars today i
like that it's almost like you have
nothing to do with it and they're like
oh sorry sorry you're out of energy
dollars i wish you would have caught me
earlier but dude i was rolling and
energy
earlier i just went along nuts with the
energy dollars it's like i give to
homeless
and then it's like bro i
just can't give every single person i'm
sorry mm-hmm catch me tomorrow though by
the way i'll catch you outside they'll
be outside it'll be outside i'm glad you
just said homeless because i feel like
someone was like oh you have to stay
temporarily unhoused is that a joke it's
dead serious that's like your thing now
no quit
i quit
i can't fucking keep pumping but you
know what he doesn't have a goddamn home
he's homeless
but here's the other type of house but i
was like i feel like tempering that
house is supposed to make you the person
saying it you feel better yeah like oh
it's just temporary and the homeless
people were like no no no i'm homeless
i'm homeless i had to snort crack
cocaine out of people's assholes
to get this five dollars you understand
me it's not temporary this is not bros
is real fire yes
shit is real i have a ring light
if i i wouldn't have a ring light in my
homeless encampment had this if i
thought this was gonna end soon i washed
my ass in the bayou okay
it's a fucking real situation out here
i'm temporarily on the house fuck out of
here
are there anything tell that to real
homeless but they'll be like fuck you
man i'm homeless i know i was trying to
sleep under a bridge bitch people always
say they're like in l.a the homeless
problem the homeless problem the home
the homeless people i'm like
if you think the
like that unhoused
the real problem in l.a is the people
with homes the housed those are the ones
i'm afraid of yeah the people that
actually are buying real estate in la
right now i went to buy a look at a
house um and it was whatever it was and
i was like oh maybe i should put an
offer in i'm calling to see if you know
my credit score is you know it it can
get sketchy it's comedian um and uh
by the time i checked the credit score
it had already been bought in cash for 2
million over in cash
and then no one has lived in it for four
years so basically they just are putting
their money money
and then i found out later chris brown
lived next door so i was like maybe
that's fine yeah
but that was i feel like he's been
redeemed so i don't know um but uh yeah
i don't know what that's like i think
like it's so interesting to me how like
rappers like impervious to cancellation
is pretty amazing throw some d's on that
bitch yeah pour some dudes who let the
dogs out
guys don't punch down exactly i'm not
saying
rappers i'm just saying comedians
don't come for us it's just weird this
is the odd time like snoop dogg is the
most uncancellable motherfucker
he went off on gail king calling you
bitch ass cunt like i don't know what he
didn't say like he left it all out there
and then all of a sudden he's doing a
corona commercial i'm like how
are you doing this
it's amazing he's like and the kaiser
permanente yeah
he's incredible for the list of all
these he's invincible not only is he
invincible he's there to repair brand
names covid and coronavires was such a
big thing corona beer was having a
meeting like who can fix this and some
guy's like senor yo pinto snoop dogg
persona for this and bad bunny put bad
bunny and snoop dogg in a corona
commercial this will fix it all right
he's fucking amazing he uncanceled the
olympics larry nassar molested hundreds
of girls and they're like what do we do
no one's gonna watch the olympics like
snoop dogg is gonna comment on the
horses yes it'll be great
kevin great bring kevin snoop dogg's
watching dressage and the the horse gets
to they get a trophy and there's like
the jockey shouldn't get the trophy the
horse should get it yeah
walk under the bridge that's it a hero
that's it a legend how
incredible it's incredible i think when
you know someone's heart yeah that's
what it is and that's why when i'm like
oh snoop has a great heart if someone's
gonna come for that's my thing now is
that when people are worried about
getting canceled i'm like why are you
worried
yeah you know like there's a point where
it's like people know your character or
they don't and i'm like i'm kind of at a
point where i'm like you fuck with me or
you don't i have no secrets i've said a
lot of crazy shit
in the context of joe if you can't you
just don't like me yeah exactly and
that's okay like don't try to pretend
it's like punching down or offensive you
just don't like me and that's fine you
don't you know but i think that i'm also
the point where i'm like you know my
character you know my heart and we all
know we know snoop has a good heart we
can't explain why it's the heart for
sure and also like expecting anybody to
be perfect is just outrageous and we
know his circumstances and we know his
story yeah it's just sort of like um
you know there is it is funny when
someone clearly is a piece of garbage
but we're like gods
our kelly it was just like good jam
the jams are so good yeah you know so
but you know it is that is really
interesting we focus so much on the
people that do get quote unquote
cancelled and the ones that don't and
why you know you're like because i do
think there's a lot of people that have
ill will and then something also like
i'm sure business interests are being
preserved like also you know like
i think corporations that are like
making so much money off a particular
individual that's gotten so big and so
strong yeah that's doing
really terrible things on the side
and then they're protected pretend to
protect and then when they've taken
every single penny that they could out
of this person then they're like okay
now cancel them yeah well i think it's
also clear if with someone like snoop
we all know when someone's
intentionally misunderstanding just to
be offended i agree you're intentionally
taking this out of context you're
intentionally saying this in a way
that's not supposed to be said you're
intentionally writing this out because
it's supposed to be performed so that
you you know what i mean you fucking
nerd this is a
man i remember my friend was having a
real breakdown and he called his
spiritual teacher and he was just like
having this moment with his teacher was
like do you know i did this and you know
i did that i'm like so terrible i'm
trying to be bad isn't that did you know
this about me like i feel that and he
just he just goes
i always
think the best of you
and i think if people
worked hard
to see the best in people before they
just see the worst
it'd be like a really different place
this is corny but i'm that's i just felt
like i had a super corny but super real
moment
yes
stop looking in the eyes yeah stop it
geez i was struggling so hard with just
forgiving humanity in general like i
realized i was just scared of people and
and you know the dyslexia of i'm not
scared of you know animals and pit bulls
and horses the things most people are
scared of i feel very safe around but
human beings just scared the shit out of
me and um
and then i started doing 30 days before
everyone that walks by just looking at
them and thinking i love you yeah and
wow it
changed my life like it's it's just a
little hack of like there is no one that
isn't lovable there's no one that didn't
start out
perfect you know and just the idea of
like um
saying i love you to someone in your
head it's like a walking meditation just
like i love you i love it it just it
really helped me that's really great i
did it um i realized like my niece
caroline is like the love of my life and
she i when i get frustrated with someone
or someone's driving or i hate someone
i'm like that's someone's caroline
that's it everyone know what i mean like
someone loves that person as much as i
love caroline so like i have to be kind
to that and also we're all kids we're
all five like when i'm struggling with
someone i think it's really sweet yeah
it's just like also i was trying to
think of something clever and hilarious
but i just didn't want to ruin that
moment
the fuck out of here what are we doing
that's what comedians i love you love
you there's some real shit out here on
the streets with me
talking about i love you love you you
love the wrong person some terrible shit
could happen to you but yeah you could
have empathy and care for them but
there's so to every like i see people
also as kids you know like i see him as
like five years old i see that too a lot
like i'll see someone as a kid and then
their anger or their whatever i'm like
oh you're just scared yeah my friend
told me one time he's like he's like
we're nothing more than overgrown
children that's it
so much pain who were just like when is
the damocles sword gonna fall and i'm
gonna die because we are so or so our
brain is so over developed compared to
most other mammals like we know so much
about like yeah we know nothing yes
we're correct we're nothing well we're
so focused on survival that we're not
actually we're spending so much time
learning how to stay safe safe an
environment that's relatively safe
there's no tigers anymore we have door
guys we have locks on our doors but
we're still like you know uh in fight or
flight mode even when we're safe so it's
so hard for us to like develop these
tools so
so sorry to focus on this but you
bringing up the like the prayer and
meditation it's like that feels like
teaching
it's universal we should be doing that
to get us out of our fight our flight
mode smoking obviously is addictive
because of nicotine but i was talking to
a doctor who was saying such a big part
of why smoking is so addictive and
relaxing is because you're just taking
deep breaths yeah of course and it gives
you an opportunity to step away
you're basically meditating yeah no i
100 and breath is like
so not really paid attention to at all
you can get high off your breath yeah
you can't you can absolutely get high
off your breath
and uh there was a story of this guy
that wanted to get enlightenment so he
went to a monk he wanted to be a monk
and he was just like please teach me
please teach me he walks up to this monk
please teach me the piece i want to be a
monk i want to be like you i want to be
like you please teach me and he just
grabs him and he puts his head in the
water and he holds it holds it holds and
holds and holds it holds and holds it
guy starts fighting he lets him go
he gets up and he goes surely we're one
breath away from non-existing
like people forget man it's like you
better worry about your breath be
conscious of your breath breathe
you cannot uh have an activated amygdala
uh emitting cortisol and take deep
breaths i don't know what the fuck
you're talking about this is just
cortisol help arabic you have so much
like advice
you do so much good work way i'm like no
no no no this is so good what is that it
just well i've been actually i've spent
no i've spent most of my life trying to
dis deactivate my brain to constantly be
in fight or flight mode all the time
being at war all the time so part of
like the work that you're doing is so um
i'm so
inspired and humbled by it but um for
this reason because committing to being
present in our life and conscious i feel
like most of my life i just wasn't
conscious i was just scared scared so
how do i stay it's like
surviving not thriving sorry that it
rhymes but the idea is to thrive in life
and not just survive like every day i
was just like survive that day how am i
gonna get through tomorrow like that's
not life that's not that's not it and
then of course the that's okay though
like sometimes you need those days you
just need to push through and shit and
it just gets really heavy and you do
just need to get through this day but if
you don't have a choice of a respite of
a break you know we talked earlier about
like gratitude like even if you're not
feeling grateful it gives your heart a
break it gives your brain a break the
other things that give your heart and
brain a break are drugs alcohol sex all
these mouth things that can like really
hurt people so i'm just knowing that i'm
you know one inch away from choosing
those anesthetics i'm always looking for
ways to make sure i don't need to reach
for that anesthetic in the first place
because i know how that ends you know
and so many people are in so much pain
like it's just something that uh i just
i want to break that ancestral cycle
sure like i'm like this is gonna stop
with me yeah it's tough
if possible but i farted it's tough no i
mean doing the work is tough and also
like that is a real thing the ancestral
trauma is a real thing they found a
study that dna carries memories
100 that's a whole nother thing you
could be like
not even doing anything negative you
just have it in your fucking bloodline
and all of your you don't even know
where it's coming from what ostensibly
are irrational fears you're crazy you're
a pussy you're afraid of heights it's
like they now can those are all things i
am at you
know first of all like cliffs are like
scared heights are scary like i i just
like my balls tickle every time i look
down and then i figured out that like a
lot of people both
have like tickling in their genitalia
when they look down
from uh from like a really tall building
like a substantial amount of people sure
i think like the majority right both men
and women i thought it was just a man
thing like your balls tickle but but all
of a sudden you know women will tell me
like no i have the same thing i feel a
little tickled yeah totally and the fear
yeah what is that why are you hating the
big delay why is it right at your
genitals that's very interesting
[Laughter]
yeah no it's more like he yikes yeah so
there's um maybe it's like his life
comes from there i don't know
so
we do not know no yeah like in 50
because
many mammals retract their reproductive
organs when in danger so what you're
feeling is your body's memory of being
able to do that it's not happening but
it's what you're you're the epigenic
imprinting of that
wow
when you're in danger but when you're on
so that so that that your reproductive
organs don't get harmed by the
ostensible danger that might be on the
horizon okay great um fascinating but
the study of the mice that were
electrocuted every time they smelled a
cherry blossom their offspring
when they
had them smell cherry blossom they were
coiled to the other end even though
there was no shock so that's one
generation passed on that's one
epigenetic fear passed on with just one
generation you know so whatever our
parents went through that they you know
the pain the horror it
we carry it whether we like it or not
whether we even know it or not and the
epigenetic imprinting of what happened
in our past like i have coal mining
ancestry in mind and i never like
explored the trauma but like being in
elevators like loud noises are really
scary to me just like i was like weird
about birds for a while like i just was
like birds are fucking spooky like you
can't they are though kind of they're
just like i get it they don't you can't
reason with them
no don't care and they also have like
they can just fly in kamikaze any moment
dude owls dive bomb people birds are
pretty emily's the expert on crows but
birds
see i knew some shit was up with birds
even when i was a kid everyone's like
they're just birds and i was like dude
they know they're dinosaurs yeah they're
dinosaurs they have some ancestral
imprint they've got some ancestral
wisdom we don't even fucking know about
like if birds got their shit together
and they were just like hey if millions
of us just gather we could just fuck up
these times if they watched the movie
birds were fucked
if they could really just process that
movie they would mobilize the media like
these little bitch-ass
human beings cannot handle us if they
knew how much power they had yeah we'd
be in a lot of trouble yeah crows can't
hold grudges they recognize faces
they hold grudges up to four years now i
just want to kill every crow i get in
touch with well no i know people are
like
memorizing your face i could just see
him like open up his beak and then all
of this knowledge that is a chinese
drone and then you know it they're for
sure packs of wolves from the sky yes
they can control packs vultures can
solve crimes
well that's because they have a pleasure
[Laughter]
to survive
they have to find them yeah they have to
find the body it's what they do
what are you talking about that makes
the most sense these crows controlling
wolves is so weird
what are they doing i end these very
awkwardly i could talk to you forever i
hope we get to be friends
what do you mean i thought we are
friends okay good
that's kind of weird now i felt so i
shared so many intimate things
so i'd love to be friends at some point
yeah we should continue to be friends i
hope at some point we can have like a an
authentic vulnerable talk yeah i think
so i think like someday someday i don't
want to push it i would absolutely love
it we should do like chocolate mushrooms
and hang out what is that oh that is um
uh in my two specials ago i had a robot
built to look like me that came out at
the end because i did most of my
mistakes most of my jokes were about uh
i did a whole thing on robots on sex
robots and what they're what's gonna
happen
and that's probably really good i
haven't tried a six robot i was gonna
say and my gift to you
for coming on the podcast is actually so
she talks and her body got sawed in half
in a
in a movie but she just lives up there
her name's bear claw
bear claw yeah it's really very dumb
um it's just interesting i'm usually
creeped out by these things but that one
i don't know why it's just like
it feels fine you know what people
always who it was neil brennan who said
but here's what neil brennan said neil
brennan was like the reason the robot
that looks like you isn't creepy is
because in real life you look like a
robot
that's really funny
wait before we go will you plug your
show and tell us everywhere to find you
you're everywhere it's the number it's
like the number one show enough it
wasn't just trending is it's just it was
top 10 for a hot minute and it's just
like it's it's great the reviews are
it's a hundred percent the reviews
critics that go out of their way to be
shitty to good shows they're like this
is
yeah
it's really it's like it's like
embarrassing how positive the reviews
are
like in terms of this is starting to
feel paid yeah it was like what's going
on we need one negative review just so
we know everyone's i was like wait yeah
no it's beautiful it's that good of a
show really well received it's on
netflix it's called mo
[Music]
it's also not only about this it's just
one of the funniest most profound shows
that has been on television a very long
time
all of the
pathos and you know
it's about a show about belonging it's
about
uh displacement it's about statelessness
shoes
but it's about people that just want to
be feel seen and feel like equal to the
person next to them it relates to
everybody it's not just about refugees
immigrant societies anybody working
paycheck to paycheck trying to survive
while suppressing emotional pain
and you know
potentially getting addicted to
drugs to try to help them navigate the
world that's just making it worse and
creates more um
issues for them with their families and
their relationships and
your girl in the show is theresa
so
and i and and there's these things that
happen in the show where it's it's get
ready
because anyone who has gone through had
you know anything that you just
mentioned which is most of us um unless
you're the person the irony is that
everyone can relate to your show except
the producers that bought it it's always
like this weird thing where it's like
you know um but the situation where her
credit was bad because she had a family
member take out credit cards that
happened to me too oh really i've never
seen that in a show i've never seen
anyone talk about that before and i
didn't realize how common it was
that's pretty amazing yeah i mean like
we sat down with the writers we're like
we got to have like we're just trying to
dive into each character and give them
their space but she's amazing today says
i made the whole cast and also thank you
for like her life hard things happen and
she's just like got it got it i wanted
to make like an adult how most women
respond we're just like got it cool
keep going her character
was inspired by for me like when i was
imagining like what she did for a living
aside from her being like an authentic
grounded mexicana
playing a mexicana
and like not somebody who's trying to
put on an accent it's like who she is
but also like being a strong woman
running a mechanic shop is inspired by
marissa tome my cousin vinnie i was just
like if i
i was just like whenever the movie ended
and i saw how spectacular she was
talking about cars i could just close my
eyes and see her in that world
i was like man i wish
i wish i got to see that you know aside
from just imagining it i wish somebody
made that into a reality or show i was
like well if i ever
you know have my own show whenever i do
i'll just
make
a female character like such a like a
boss babe just running an entire
business
and just like and just you know i want
to see that world what does that look
like when she's walking through and
doing that hopefully we get to explore
that more in season two but and also it
also felt kind of prof i like to get
like i'm an allegory bitch and like uh i
mean cars are identified as she you know
it's kind of like this sort of
interesting so amazing i didn't even put
that link thing as my brain um
but uh also just the choice of she gets
this dev this she gets this really
heartbreaking phone call and it's just
like you know the uh the place most
people would go because sometimes when i
watch tv i'm always like oh no like
you're you're like this is going so well
don't and she's just like got it got it
okay and that was it
she swallows it it's not but she's a
woman wouldn't she cry and scream and
yell at the person and be like what you
know it was just like that's that's some
survivor shit is like and that to me is
the most interesting television because
that's what it's actually like like
writers who just sit around and go like
well how do we make this interesting and
how do we make it dramatic and emotional
by doing by playing it for fucking real
the way the tragedy would actually
present itself which the only the women
the main characters the main women in
the show are extremely powerful my mom
my sister
uh my girlfriend are all like very
strong
characters that have their own issues of
course in their own fault but it's not
going but strong woman it's always like
that's just a woman yeah it's just like
it's just one it's just like handling
business because there's no other job
it's very natural you don't get to
luxuriate in your emotions right when
you're paycheck to paycheck exactly you
don't have the luxury of like being
depressed and having a bad day and being
anxious and it's like so when you see
like the affluent people in our world
you know in america especially when i
have an anxiety disorder it's like they
have all that too there's just no time i
love the flip too where
moe's broke the main characters and his
girl is the one that is actually doing
yeah yeah so well
and one of the things i laugh at i mean
there's a lot that i still laugh at in
the show even though i've seen every
episode like 40 fucking times when i'm
editing it but
i just love it so much but it's just in
episode four when he's like i'll take
care just leave it up to me enough to go
and do that and she's like it's just
like right in his face he just has to
like
just eat that and he knows she's right
like he's not gonna be able to do it and
then he has to go figure it out and he
gets into trouble
so she didn't handle it perfectly yeah i
don't know you didn't handle it
perfectly
and it's like brutal honesty too it's
just a way of like
like just sticking to the side like yeah
i love you but but i love that and
that's
real accidentally accidental
emasculation but also what am i going to
walk on eggshells and be like oh yeah
okay baby yeah exactly and that's why
they're too real of a relationship for
them to do that i love you i'm gonna cut
these are awkward don't ride elephants
um moe has two specials on netflix uh
get to them immediately and then his
show um on netflix as well more and more
to come and also get into a wormhole in
the talk show appearances one of my
favorite stories is uh is your flag
story on jimmy
get out of my house
what are you doing just your linger
linger
he's lingering
[Music]
ah
[Applause]